slow button is a senior front-end
developer and popular YouTube video
creator in this course he's going to
teach you how to create a full stack Web
Store using angular node.js and stripe
if you're looking to build an e-commerce
store you're in the right place because
I'm going to show you how easy it is to
build it in this tutorial I'm going to
use angularjs typescript node.js and
express.js and we are going to do start
payment integration we are going to use
angular material component library and
we are going to use Tailwind to help us
to start not Material component and this
tutorial is only for teaching purposes
so we are not going to be creating the
real products but we are going to use
fixer API in order to help us
prerequisite for this video is to have
no JS installed on your machine if you
have angular fundamentals go check my
course on YouTube if you're not sure and
to create account on stripe.com it's
free by the way and that's all that's
our coding
go with slova
okay on my desktop the first thing which
I want to open is my terminal so right
click and I will open up the git bash
here
you can open up the terminal Powershell
whatever you're using
for me it's git bash now the first thing
that you want to have is npm installed I
assume that you already installed the
npm now let's install the angular CLI
this will help us to create new angular
project and it will help us to create
new components Services whatever we need
inside of our angular application so in
order to install it run npm I for
install
and angular
forward slash
CLI and the version is going to be
14.2.1 make sure to install the exactly
the same version otherwise you may run
into issues during the project
development installation has been done
let's clear this now we want to create
new project it's really easy to install
the new project once you have angular
CLI installed so run the command NG new
and now we need to pass the name of our
application I will just name it store
and I want to pass a couple of
parameters so I want application to
create default routing for us because
we're going to have two pages then I
want to remove the test so add a flag
skip tests because you're not going to
be
dealing with tests in this tutorial and
we want to have the application minimal
so set the minimal flag
like so
this will take some time to create the
application and install the packages I
will be right back
and application has been installed
successfully the packages installed
successfully and successfully
initialized a git repository for us okay
now we can close this
and we can
open the visual studio code
so for me it's just Visual Studio code
you may use some other
code editors of your choice so open the
folder
and I created this folder on the desktop
so it was called the store just select
the folder
I trust authors okay
and now we want to open the terminal on
the bottom
of the vs code we can close the get
started so the packages have been
already installed as you can see we have
the node modules installed and once
again if you open up the package.json
file make sure that you have the correct
version of angular installed as you can
see for me the angular core version is
14. so make sure to have the exactly the
same version now in order to start we
can just run Ng
sir
and this will start actually I'm running
on the Powershell it may come with
issues so I need to open up
the git Bash
and now just go NG serve
[Music]
this should start our local
server it says do I want to share the
pseudonymous usage data no I don't want
to
that has been disabled
we just want to develop the application
nothing else
and once the compilation has been done
we can open up the localhost 4200 and
see that our app is running so the first
thing that I want to do is I want to go
to the source app and access our app
component
so inside of our template
let's remove
here this boilerplate code
like so
and put it out router output we can
remove that as well this is the place
where we are going to be placing our
components so what I wanted to do the
first thing is I want to add the angular
material this is the library that we are
going to be using for creating all the
components so it's easier to develop and
faster if I go to angular material
documentation you can see the list on
the sidebar you can see the list of all
the components that I have in order to
use the specific components for example
like table
you need to go to the API of this
component and you can import it import
this module inside of your app modules
and you can see the examples how to use
it you just need to go to view code and
you can see and you can play around with
it it's really easy to implement and I
highly advise you to go to the material
documentation website first before you
start developing and play around with
these components because these are the
components that we are going to be using
throughout the development
now
let me add the angular material in order
to add it let me first clear the console
I I will just run NG add at
okay
and you add as angular
forward slash material
[Music]
like so
would you like to proceed yes
and installing all the packages
you can save our app component.ts file
it asks us what is the theme defaulting
that you want to install and I will
choose the first one as you can say as
you can see here it says Indigo pink
it's good enough for me so actually you
need to be focused on the terminal to
select the indigo set up Global angular
material typography Styles yes
include and enable animations yes so
just click enter you can select the
option with uh
with the arrow up and the arrow down and
just click enter when you want to
confirm and with this we have added all
the angular material uh files that we
need now in order to use them inside of
our application we actually need to open
up the app modules file in here we need
to install all the modulus and import
them in order to use them so here inside
of the Imports array let's just add all
the components that we want to use so
I'm going to be using the matte
side now let's first import all the
modules and later on we can just focus
on developing and we don't have to
play around with the configuration
importing the modules and things like
that so when I sign up module
the next one is going to be
matte grid
list module this one is obviously for
the grid the setting up is for our
layout and basically we're going to have
the sign up on the left side with the
filters and the categories
the next one is mat manual module
we're going to have a couple of menus
obviously
then next one is going to be matte
button module
okay then math card module most of the
elements is going to be
placed inside of the card modules card
module give you a nice uh Styles around
your elements
[Music]
Mad Card module
next one is matte icon module so we will
we will have a couple of icons as well
obviously and icon module matte
X tension expansion module this one is
going to be for the expansion expansion
filters on the left sidebar
next one is matte list module also for
the left sidebar
then Matt toolbar
module this is going to be used in the
header because we're going to have a
couple of components that that are going
to be using uh the toolbar
next one is mat table
module you're going to have table on the
cart page then the next one is Matt
badge
module
this one is for adding the badge uh
inside of our cart icon because our cart
icon is going to have a badge and
displayed how many items is inside of
the card so this module is for that
that matte snack snack bar module
this one is for displaying the
information snack bar for displaying
information uh to the user so maybe
you're adding the item to the to the
card or you're removing or maybe you're
creating new product whatever you're
doing you can notify the user for that
and this module is for that
and this sums up all the modules that
you're going to be using now we just
need to import these files because we
have imported them inside of the Imports
array but they need to be imported into
this file so we can use the import on
top and let's do this for all these
modules so import
ant
module from
angular material
this one is from side nav you see the
auto completion there and we can just
copy paste this couple of times it's
going to be easier for us
so just copy paste
like so and obviously we need to update
the URL
my menu matte button
copies
make sure to
copy it correctly so we are replacing
the same side module here then matte
icon module
then matte expansion module
then Matt list module
let me come let me paste a couple more
times okay
let's remove this
dots
commas actually then let me copy paste
the other ones my toolbar that's table
module
that badge module
and matte snack bar module
okay let me remove these commas and now
let me update so for the grid list it's
going to be from grid list
from menu is going to be from menu
button is going to be angular material
button
cart is going to be from cart
actually
icon angular material icon
expansion model from the expansion
sign up
actually toolbar is going to be from the
toolbar
table from the table
batch from the badge
snack bar
from the snag bar and the list module
from the angular material list module
and now we have done a lot of stuff
right nobody likes them
the setup and the modules import but
this once we once we've done this on the
beginning we can focus on coding and we
don't have to worry about what we have
important and what we haven't so but the
thing that that you need to know is that
we're only importing the components that
you need in our application and as you
can see there are a bunch of components
in the angular material but you're only
using the ones and important ones that
we're using that application
the next thing that I want to import and
create in our project is Tailwind
Tailwind is utility CSS library and it
helps you to
that style but the position your
elements easier so for the components we
are using the angle material but for
additional styling in the for faster
development we're going to use the
Tailwind
so in order to to install it you can
just go to tailwind and you can play
around it's very nice utility library
and they have really great documentation
so whatever the property that you need
to use you can search and find really
easily
okay
so in order to install it uh you just
follow up the documentation so as you
can see npm install Dash the tail in CSS
both CSS and auto prefixer these are all
the packages that you need in order to
to run the Tailwind so let's run that
inside of the
root folder run just this npm install
once that is done let me clear the
console
we can initialize detailed in CSS so we
need to create a configuration file make
sure to copy it
and now let's open up the token config
file it's here in the root folder
Tailwind config.js file the thing which
we want to add as you can see here it
says configure your template paths so we
want to tell the Tailwind what are what
are the templates that we want to style
right to use so here we're basically
targeting The Source folder and all the
folders inside of the source folder
these are stars that that are targeted
in that
and we want to Target all the files
that I have extension HTML
and typescript
like so
so this is how we are targeting
all the templates inside of our
application
and now we need to import the utility
classes in the base classes from the
tailwind and we do that inside of the
style CSS this is our main style and you
can just go to the documentation and
basically imp copy paste
the code from the
from this terminal
and you can import it at the very top
here
[Music]
okay
and now let's just run our application
and see if it runs correctly
if you have done everything
by the documentation
it's going to run without any issues the
links to all the commands from the get
is going to be in the description box
below and also link to the tailwind and
angular material is going to be in the
in the Box in the description so you can
go and play around and learn a little
bit about these libraries if you haven't
before because they're super awesome and
they will help you to develop your
applications so now the comp the project
has been compiled successfully and it
can reload because we have removed
everything from our app component file
you can see that the project is empty
now the first thing that we want to do
once that everything has been set up
correctly we want to create our first
component and that is going to be our
header components
so what we can do here
we can create new folder
and the name of the folder is going to
be components
like so and inside of the components
folder create new file
and let's name it
header or actually even better now let
me show you what is the the best tool of
the angular CLI if you want to generate
a components Services pipes directives
whatever you need inside of the angular
you can use the CLI so here we are
inside of the root folder and we can
just navigate to The Source change
directory to the source
app
components folder now let's generate new
component you can do that easily by
running the command NG generate G for
Generate C for component and name of the
components let's call it header
component
actually I'm running the Powershell and
that's not going to work so
I need to open up the git bash here
sorry
kid bash like so and I'll again let's
change the change directory to Source
app components and then NG generate
component header
like so
just wait for a couple of seconds and as
you can see you generate the component
for us now what we can do here
we can use this component
copy paste the selector and we can go
inside of the app component
inside of your template just
let me just
tell your template just paste
[Music]
the tag name CSS selector and as you can
see if I zoom in
you can see that it says header works I
can close the tailwind and angle
material here
now let's start actual developing of
this application now we can close our
app component file
can shrink down our terminal
okay inside of the header component if
you want to use the external HTML file
and not use the one inside of the TS
file you can create new a new files so
let's just create new file and name it
header
is removed it criminal case other Dot
component.html
this is the naming convention that you
want to follow the first the name of the
component dot component and then the
extension right so we have usually
header dot component.ts sometimes we
have the CSS file so whatever you need
and now
you can remove this code and we need to
include it we can remove the Styles as
well and if we want to include the
external HTML file that we just created
just run type in the template URL
property and for the value of the
property just inside of the current
directory targeting header dot component
dot HTML like so
and let me close all the other files
and let me just open up the HTML file
so
as you already know this file is on the
very top of our application
and on this header we want to have the
link to the home and we want to have the
card
so all the time you can see if we have
added some components or actually the
products to the card so on the very top
we are going to use the matte toolbar
component
so we are start using the angular
material component so this component
gives you nice uh nice component that
styles
similar to the card and where you can
Target and where you can place your tool
tools basically so inside of it let's
create first link to the home so like I
said it's going to have the router
link to the home
slash home okay and we can type in code
with slova store or you can name it I
store or however you want to call it
okay and on the right side
just save that up
and we get this we get this nice as you
can see nice gray background here okay
okay a couple of things I want to add
here so the first thing I want to add
the maximum bit to our container so I
don't wanna our website to take the full
width of every single device right
because you can open it up on very large
devices so set the max width to 7xl
and set the MX to Auto this means that
the module F and the right basically
horizontal is going to be Auto and it's
going to Center our container and let's
add some border on the left and the
right side or X like so
now on the right side we want to add the
icon so use the matte icon like I said
it's going to be card icon and the name
of the icon is shopping
underscore cart
like so
and as you can see we got the icon now
in order to style these two I want to
actually apply some of these stallion
Styles so I want to separate these two
and place them on the edges just zoom
out a little bit
so in order to do that I just need to to
run the class justify between
like so and they're placed uh you know
on the edges of this container
in order to apply the justify between
you basically need to have the element
that has the display Flex Rule and the
metal toolbar already has this rule set
up
now inside of the map icon you want to
show the count of the items that are
added to the to the icon how we use that
how we do that is using the matte patch
so add the input property matte badge
and let's for now just add something
statically let's add one
and as you can see we get this item
added so it's really easy and really
fast as you can see to to style uh and
add components using Gengar material if
you want to change the color you can
just use the matte batch color property
badge
or the attribute actually and I'm gonna
use warn because this is going to add a
red color to our batch that's very nice
cool
and now we want to add the button
actually that is going to open the menu
once we click on the shopping cart we
want to add a menu so this button needs
to
surround our icon so let me
let me move the icon inside of the
button
and this button is going to be matte
icon button so this is the the component
for the buttons that hold the icons
obviously okay
and then we want to add an attribute for
the manual matte menu
trigger 4. and here you define what are
you triggering for so once you click on
the button you want to trigger the menu
and this is the name of the menu and
below this we can add the matte menu
okay let me just get back together
component
here below that add math menu
like so
and for the
40
for the selector we are using the menu
here this needs these two needs to be
the same right
so this is how you target the menu and
add
value as matte menu okay now instead of
the menu let's set it there
and let's have some classes okay
so
P3
divide y divide solid
okay so the first class adds padding on
top bottom left right divide y adds the
division so basically like a separator
in between the rows inside of the this
div and we want the separation to be
solid
so yeah it's gonna we're gonna see once
we start adding some dips here let's add
the first row the first row is gonna
have the class
uh also P for padding parting bottom
three then Flex
and justify
justify between
like so so basically we're adding some
padding on the bottom we are setting
this div uh as a display flex and we
want to justify the items in between so
just to set them on the edges right and
inside of this div
let's set a span for this band we're
basically gonna say how many items do we
have
inside of our card so let's say three
items
are actually
we are using here one so let's add one
one
and let's add items
like so and let's add some margin on the
right side so class 100 right 16. like
so and on the right side we want to have
the router link
the router link
to cart this is going to be the page
that we're going to create later the
card and the home page
and the text
is viewpark
okay let's save that
if you open we get to type two items
here the one is the the length but
basically the count of the items that we
have inside of our card and the view
card and let's make the items capital i
like so
then add another div inside of this div
you're going to have all the items and
once we start fetching the items we're
gonna Loop uh we're gonna Loop and
display everything that we fetch from
the array of the items or the products
but for now it's just gonna be static uh
components
let's add a deal with the class
Flex again justify
between
and
font
light margin button too so again we are
setting the div to the flex we want to
separate the items on the edges of the
container set the font to be light so to
be very light and the margin that's a
margin on the bar margin margin bottom
two so inside of this div
let's add item name like keyboard
and the quantity is like one and then on
the right side we want to add the price
of it so let's add a class
font bold
not italic
actually they shouldn't be italic as
it's spam not an eye and let's add a
price
we can put that inside of the angular
expression y we will see right now so if
we add like 150 dollars only it's very
expensive for a keyboard just add a pipe
currency like so
now if we save it we'll see that it will
add
here it adds here uh basically the the
dollar sign the default currency is
dollar but with the parameters here you
can add a different occurrences I
believe the dollar one as default that's
not a problem for me
uh the one thing that I want to add is I
want to add some some padding here so
inside of
inside of this there actually we want to
have a container
here and let's put inside of this
container all the
products that we have so add a p y three
so this means basically I had a padding
on top and the bottom
like so so there's some separation now
when we start looping we can just start
adding these these items like so and it
will just add them below as you can see
here
and on the bottom let's add another div
here we're gonna show the total summary
so air attacks total
and add another span
here at a class on Bold
and add like a total again we can use
the currency pipe and let's say
450
[Music]
and let's use the currency pipe like so
let's save that
and I just want to add some separation
so let's add here the class
again let's add a flex
justify
between
I had some padding on top and the bottom
and let's use Font light as well
like so
okay now we have all these things
and on the very bottom so underneath
this total div I want to add two icons
so the first one is going to be to
remove everything from the card so to
clear the card and the second one is
going to be to go to the checkout right
so add a div and let's add a class again
potting padding top
uh three you can start it is flex and
justify between
like so and inside of this
add two buttons so this these are going
to be the buttons so these are going to
be the buttons that are going to hold
the icons so add a class BG rows for the
first one 600 this is going to add the
red color to our to our button
text White
around it
cool this is going to make a circle out
of our button
set the width to B9 and a height to be
9.
okay and inside of our button let's add
our icon
icon and the first one is going to be
remove underscore shopping
underscore cards
okay
and if we say
we get this remove card and and as you
can see we added this background rows
600 this is the the different color and
if you want to change the color so
basically you just choose the the color
that you want to add and with these
numbers you're adding the shade so if I
go and type in for example 300
let me show you so it will basically
show that the lighter version of of the
roads and if you go like 900
it will show you the darker version I
like the 600 so I will leave it as it is
here and let's copy paste this one we
want to add another icon
and this icon is actually gonna have
it's going to be just a link so router
link
and let's it's gonna link to the record
and the background is going to be green
instead of rose
everything else Remains the Same
and yeah rounded tool means basically
that we are added border radius so if
you remove the border around is full let
me show you
[Music]
it shows a square so that's why I'm
adding router full and this is basically
the width and the height of the button
with
W and H
and with that we can complete it our
menu and basically our header so now we
can start actually developing our home
page
our landing page and in order to do that
let's open up
our source tree and inside of the app
let's create a new folder and name it
page
Pages actually inside of the pages
we're going to use the angular CLI
here
again CD into let me actually see where
we are at any components CD on the
topper directory and let's change
directory to the pages
okay
and here we want to create new component
NG generate component
now let's call it home component
it will take for a couple of seconds and
as you can see it creates the component
home components inside of the home
folder
and it updates the app module so if you
go to the app module
as you can see here
we got the home component imported
inside of this file and it has been
imported into the Declarations array so
in order to use the component if you
haven't been using the Standalone
component
you need to import them inside of the
module in order to use it
now inside of the app routing module
we want to add the first route
so the name of this route is going to be
home
and the component
that is going to be loading this is
going to be the component that we just
created so its name is home component
like so
and also what we want to do is
we want to add this path as default so
how we do that is
we'd add another object and inside of
this object we add a path
to empty
and we add redirect to
home
and add path match
too full
and make that as a string so what this
does is basically if you enter the M3
empty string so if you just go to
localhost it will redirect to the home
and then the component will home
component will load this this is how it
works so in order to load these routes
we actually need to go to the app
components folder and here we need to
add the router Outlet
like so
and we need to close that
tag
like so and now we have the app
component loading our com component
actually so depending on the on the
route it loads the correct component and
as you can see if you just type in
localhost 4000
actually four thousand let me remove it
the extension
the protocol actually and we get the
Home Route added to it and we get the
homeworks
so now we can close
the app routing module we can close the
app component
we can close the header component and we
can start developing our common
component so let's open up the home
component
Pages home like so and once again let's
remove this template
as you will going to be creating the new
folder new file template URL external
HTML file so the name is going to be
inside of the current
folderhome.com component
.html and we can copy this
and just add new file here
or you can use this option like so
and save this
okay now we can shrink down our terminal
and let's start developing later HTML
code so here we're going to use the
matte
drawer drawer container
this is the component from angular
material and what it does it basically
creates a drawer or a sidebar which
which it can pop up or stay always the
open which is the case in this uh in
this application so
add a property Auto
size to True which means that basically
it's gonna
true which means that it's going to
recall recalculate what are the values
and the width of the container elements
and if there's something loading
dynamically it's gonna Auto size it
again
let's add also we want to add a couple
of more classes here so let's add a
class uh let's set the mid height to be
full so to take the full height of the
window
let's add a Max maximum width as we did
on the same on the here on the toolbar
maximum width to be
7xl now let's add MX photo so basically
this means
margin on the left and the right side
horizontally
to be Auto so it basically centers your
container now let's add border on the
left and on the right side
like so
okay
so if we
zoom out you can see that we have this
container and we have borders on the
left on the right side
let me zoom in again
okay
and inside of this matte draw container
we'll have one drawer which is basically
like like I said uh
the sidebar
match drawer
and the mode here is going to be side
these modes can change the way how this
drawer works yeah you can you can set it
to overflow of the content but if it's
set to side it means that it pushes the
main content so it's not overflowing any
any layout
and we want to set it always to be
opened
open like so and let's just add
uh some give here that says filters it's
going to do it's going to be the
categories but it says filters as you
can see it's always open here so you
cannot close it because we added this
property
and let's add some padding to this
pairing six like so
that's good
[Music]
okay
now on the right side of this matte
drawer container we're gonna have
matte drawer
content
so this is going to take the biggest
portion of our page my drawer content
and I want to add some padding there as
well so add padding six
like so and here we're gonna create new
a new component
uh which is going to be called app
products header so inside of our pages
folder add new folder and name it
components
so this folder is going to hold all the
components that are inside of the home
page right so the components inside of
the app folder are components that are
that are being shared across the entire
application inside of the pages we have
the home and actually we need to place
this component inside of the home page
like so move it and now inside of this
component let's create new components
now let me see where we are at in our in
our tree in the pages now it's CDs
change directory inside of the
components
let me just see
okay we need to change directory to home
to components and now let's uh NG
generate component now let's call it
well what we said products
products header
this component is gonna have
some elements that are going to help our
us to sort and to display products
differently
okay
and inside of let me just
open this component and again let's
create new file
here like so and let's call it products
Dash header
dot com on end dot HTML
now let's include that okay
here instead of inside of the template
just
add
that and let's
change the property to the URL like so
and let's remove the Styles here okay
[Music]
now we need to use this
selector CSS selector and inside of the
home component
inside of the matte drawer content we'll
just include
just include that
here
like so and we can close the other
components
and we can just focus on the coding this
part
and on this component on the left side
we will have a button that will change
the Sorting ascending or descending and
on the right side we'll have one button
which will change the number of products
that you display on the page and the
third element is just to change the
layout of these product items so let's
begin we will place that inside of the
Mad Card element
and let's add some margin on the bottom
so margin bottom four
added another div
and let's set a class of flex and
justify
between
so again on this div we are setting this
div to have the display as flags and
they're justifying elements between them
so it means that the one on the left
side we're gonna have one button and on
the other side we'll have two menus but
they will be separated totally and they
will be on the edges of this container
okay
now create another div and inside of
this div let's create a button
[Music]
for that menu
this button we will have
matte matte button argument or property
which will transform the regular button
into the matte button so
and it will have text sort by and let's
add a dummy description let's say
now we want to create a menu for this
button so if I save this
you can see that we created this button
but let's create a menu so once we click
on the sort we should get a menu and we
can change the the ascending sorting by
descending or ascending and we do that
by passing the mat
menu
trigger four
this is the property and we need to pass
the name of the manual and the name is
going to be sort by menu
below this button let's create the menu
and the menu is going to have matte menu
tag
and now let's give this name
that we are using to Target this menu
and we need to pass the math menu
so by the sort by menu basically we are
creating an ID we are adding the ID to
this to this menu and that's how we
target it and connect this matte menu
with this button okay
and now if you save that
we should get an empty menu like so
and in this menu which we should create
two buttons which will change the
Sorting the first one is going to be
descending
and the second one is going to be
ascending
and also
let's add matte menu item
property to both of these
like so and now what we can do is we can
create a sort
variable which we can update so let me
just check the HTML if it run this
correctly it does as you can see
and what we can do here is we can just
create a variable and name it as a sort
and give it a default value to sort
and we can change this desk to the
variable
like so
and then we can create a new method
which will update this
okay
it
probably does doesn't exist on the prop
products so because it's sorts and task
this is the name of the property
sort by
and sort needs to have the descending
the default value not sort okay
and we can create a create new function
or actually method on sort updated
this method is going to return the void
so it's not going to return anything
it's just going to update this variable
here so it needs to accept new sort
parameter
to this type of string
and all it does is
it updates the sort on this one on this
class
to new new source equals new source
like so later on we will emit this value
and we will fetch the results but for
now this this is just
the regular functionality okay and now
we need to call that method one click so
here on click
call the
on sort
updated method and for the first one
send the description
so in that description descending
it's a little bit confusing and for the
second one
send the ascending
like so
and if I save this
when we select you should change the
value
and later like I said we will go and
basically
emit the new value and we'll fetch the
data according to this value
so we will just sort it differently okay
and with that we have completed the the
left sorting manual let's proceed with
the second part
okay so on the right side let's create
another div
[Music]
and let's set a class Flex again
and items Center
this means that we want to align the
items horizontally
not
actually vertically so they need to be
in in line with this sort by description
everything needs to be in line okay
so let's add another div
and here we again uh want to create
another menu so
let's add a button again
and this button is also going to be
matte
button
and again let's add matte menu trigger
matte menu
trigger for property
or and if you receive the menu it will
actually be targeted and connected with
the menu this is the ID that I was using
so math
manual and let's add
the ID of menu and it's math menu I mean
this could be more descriptive but on
this component we only have these two
menus so it should be it should be good
enough
okay
and then
here I want to add a text dream show and
here we will basically uh show the
number of items so let's add a new
variable and uh let's call it call it
items show count
okay and let's create that new variable
here
items show count and let's set the
default value to 12 I think yeah let's
use 12. okay
[Music]
and if I save it here
it showed well so basically showed 12
items that that's what it means
okay
and what I want to add besides that is I
want to add an icon and the name of the
icon is expand more
so that indicates that actually we want
to we can open this one
right
and that's exactly something that we
missed for the first menu so something
that should indicate is sorting as well
that
if you want to have the expand
here yeah that's more like it
okay let me close it
and now inside of this menu we'll we'll
show different values similar like we
did for the 41st menu and actually I can
just copy paste this code so it's easier
so from the first menu let's just copy
the buttons
because here we will also have the
buttons and
just for the first item let's set the
value to 20 to 12. and let's create a
new method once this one was called on
sort updated and the new one is going to
be called on items
updated
okay
this one also doesn't return anything it
just updates divide the value here
so
it will receive the count which is a
number
[Music]
and it will update this dot items
show count
to equals to count
okay
and we can use this method now to update
this to this value
so instead of on sort we will call on
items updated
and here we will pass value of 12.
okay
[Music]
here
but let's add a couple more more items
so the second one is going to be 24.
24 and the last one
is going to be 36. so if you have any
other preferences on how many items
would you like to show on the page you
can add them here
let's save that up and if we try we can
see that this updates the values like
expected
so right now this is static it doesn't
change any data because we don't have
any data yet but later it will update
the number of items that we have on the
page okay
and the next thing which we want to add
we want to add additional div and
additional buttons where we can change
the layout
okay
so we can close this div and let's add
another button
and this button is going to hold
the matte icon and this icon
it's going to be called a view list like
so
here
and let's copy paste this two times
the second one is going to be view
module
[Music]
and the last one is going to be called
View County
[Music]
and we get these three icons and right
now they are static right but later on
they will you know update
our layout
so what we can create the method which
that we will use to to update our layout
so let's create that on columns
columns
updated
it perceives The Columns number which is
a number
and this doesn't return anything so
return type is void here
uh then we want to emit this value so we
actually need to First create event
emitter so let's add
output
and make sure to import the output from
the angular core this is the way how you
send the data outside of your component
to parent components so create
output
and let's name it column
columns count change like so and this
will be new event
emitter coming and make sure to import
it as well from angular core
okay
and it will send a number so this is the
number of columns you want to display in
a row okay
and what we can do here is basically
just call this dot columns
count change and just emit
[Music]
the number that we receive
from the template
like so
now let's call
this method inside of our HTML file
here on click
so here
we have view list on the first one we
want to show only one item per row
okay
on the second one
I want to show
three items per row and on the last one
I want to show four items per row
oops
here make sure to put them inside of the
parentheses
and now we can catch that value inside
of our parent component which is the
header component
so here
inside of the app products header
we have new events and that event is
called
uh let me just
check what is the exact name columns
count change
okay
and this is the event columns count
change and when we call that event
you can call new method
on columns
columns
count change
but we need to create this
this method inside of our home component
here
and we will we will need to create a new
variable which we will update and use
inside of the inside of our layout you
can set you can actually remove these
styles
we don't need the Stars here
and let's create a
let's create a new variable so the new
variable is going to hold the number of
items that we have per row so the
columns that we have parole is three
that is the default right
that's right
and
what we want to do is basically to
update this so This dot count
these dot calls actually calls is equal
to and we need to receive the cost
number calls number which is a number
and this method doesn't return anything
so again it's void and these calls
basically receives these this new number
right
and yeah I think that should that should
so let's just try if this works we can
go and open up the home component
and inside of the global content you can
just place the variable here
and as you can see the default value is
three
let's see if you click on this one it
should show one and if you click on this
one it should show three actually Four
yeah and on the middle one you should
show three like so this works as
expected so we can continue now and
build our actually we can first build
our categories or the filters on the
left side okay so let's create another
component and let me open up the
terminal again
here
so inside of the components folder app
pages home components folder let's
create new one NG generate component and
let's call it filters
like so it will take a couple of seconds
okay so it created a new component and
it updated Source app app module so once
again let me show you it adds new
components inside of the app module so I
don't have to do this manually so this
is the beauty of the angular CLI and
inside of the components open up the
filters so this is the new component
that we just created and again let's
remove the styles
and let's add external template URL
template URL and we will create here new
HTML file let's call it
filters Dot component.html
so let me copy this name and here in
filters create new file with the same
with the same name that we just
placed inside of the component decorator
okay
let's first create
Gories
categories array
so this component will hold the list of
the categories that we can use to filter
our our products on our website
so let's create some dummy categories
later on we will fetch this from the API
so let's say shoes
maybe Sports I don't know something that
will you just need something to use into
iterate through inside of our HTML file
okay let me close the other files so we
are not confused
and then we will use
another material component and it will
be called matte expansion panel you'll
remember this one
so this component basically uh it's like
a expansion penalty set so you will just
see the name of the title of this panel
and once you click on it you will expand
and show you all the items inside of it
so this uh
let's show this panel only if we have
the categories so NG if
categories
like so so if the categories do exist
and they are not undefined show this
otherwise just hide this panel
inside of the matte expansion panel
let's add matte expression expansion
panel header
let's remove this closing tag and let's
add a new one inside of the header
you just want to add a title which is
matte
panel
title
and it will be called
categories like so okay
let me remove caps lock and we'll have
another
matte
selection
list
okay this is another matte tag
selection always and it basically shows
the
the elements
in the list so and it will it allows you
to select one of the elements from the
list
and we want to be able only to select
one item so that's why we need to pass
the multiple multiple uh input false
attribute so if you click on true here
for the multiple we can select select
multiple items inside of this math
selection list okay
and here we have Matt list options
like so and we want to Loop through the
categories array that we just created so
create ng4
and call that category
of
categories
okay
and set the value
to be a category
like so and inside of the
this option we want to display a button
[Music]
and just place the category here
like so
if we save it actually there's one
problem with this because we haven't
included this component inside of our
inside of our sidebar so that's the
problem
now take the selector
and go inside of the home component HTML
file and instead of these filters you
need to place this component
okay
now we will see it
okay there you go
and if you click on the categories it
expands and you get the shoes and the
sports
okay now we want to emit this value so
once you click on like on the shoes on
the sports as you can see you only
select one of the items and we will have
more items here more categories but once
you select on the item we want to emit
this value to the parent component and
we can use the data to fetch the
categories right so let's do that
inside of the
template
here you can create new method
yeah let's call it
on show category
on show category
this one will return nothing so the term
void and it will receive the category
which is just a string
and this string needs to emit this value
so let's create new one
and let me import the output from
angular core
like so and let's name it show category
okay which is a new event emitter
the event
diameter okay and this one will receive
the string
actually with emit the string let me
close the folder so you can see it
it will emit the string and let's import
even emitter from angular core as well
and now when we call this method and
then we pass the category we can emit
this value so let's call this dot show
category dot emit
and pass category
okay
and let's call this method inside of our
HTML component
here inside of our button let's call
click on click event
call our method and pass the category
[Music]
okay now we can test this again
uh the event name is the show category
so here inside of our home component
we can call this method show category
and we can create new method that method
can be called on show category
and just pass the value I usually pass
the value from the from the child events
as event this is the parameter
okay
and inside of the TS class
let's add this method
this method again is not returning
anything so it returns void
and it needs to have one parameter which
is the category
and let's call it new category
cut
category like so and it will be the
string value
now
uh we need to add the new property so
let's call it category and let it be
value string and
undefined so it can be when you don't
Define it initially it needs to take uh
either of these two values so if you
initialize it right away it can be just
string but if you leave it undefined you
need to add these values that are
undefined
okay so here we call this dot category
and we assigned it new category value
and we can just
use this value to test it inside of our
home component
the same area how we are testing the
columns Let's test category and once we
click on one of these elements we should
see these values inside of our component
choose Sports it works as expected now
the next thing which I want to create on
the home page
it's I want to display the product boxes
here and it should and that should do it
after that we should fetch the actual
data and display it so let's just to sum
up what we created here we created this
card uh menu and actually I see that we
are using the two SIM icons so that
needs to be fixed uh this one is for
removal of the cards and this one is
actually for proceeding to the checkout
so open the products header and any side
of the products header
no actually it's not inside of the
product Setter it's actually in the
header component so inside of the
components folder Source app headers
we have here components we have here the
icons and one is remove shopping cart
and the other one is also remove
shopping cart so it needs to be just a
shopping cart
Let's test it yeah so this one should uh
route us to the cart as you can see here
and not to to remove the shopping cart
yeah okay so we fixed that back so just
to sum up we created this header with
this uh Home Route link we created this
card which shows the items we can go on
a new the card you can remove everything
from the car and you can proceed to the
checkout and actually this is all static
we just need to be implemented we added
this sort menu we added this show a
number of items menu we added this
layout buttons and we added the
categories on the left side now like I
said just add the products on the middle
and let's proceed to the next page and
now in the home component HTML file
let's remove this category variable
and we'll add
a wrapper to your product box component
so I'm gonna use matte grid list
component
and this component basically is a grid
so you just pass a tile child component
and it separates them into columns and
rows that's all it does so we want to
set the gutter size which is actually
the margin in between these elements so
cutter size
to 16.
so it's 16 pixels
for number of columns we want to change
this dynamically depending on the
buttons that we click here on the first
one we want to have the column number
one per Row in the in the middle three
per row and the right one four per row
but as we created this
this variable
dynamically
already so
we'll just passed the columns this
variable
and for the row height
we also want to have this dynamically
updated so let's create new variable
named row height
and let me go to the home TS file and
here we have columns that error being
three at the moment but we are updating
the columns here so for the row height
let's just create a new object that we
can use to map the heights so
create a constant named Ros
core height
and this will be an object
and this object will have three values
so the first value is obviously when you
have one one column selected or one item
Purl and it will have a height of 400
right
then the second value is when we have
three items per row and this one we will
have height of 335 and the last one is
when we have four items per row
it will have hypo 350. let's decide
the type so the type is in
object basically and the object has an
ID
number this is a key and it has value as
number
okay
just set up the view wrap word wrap so
that you can see
okay
[Music]
now what we want to do is we want to set
the row height depending on these
columns here so we can use this constant
foreign
called this dot calls
and as default one is three so we will
have three columns as default the
default height is going to be 335 but
once we update the on column count
change we want to update this value as
well so
we will basically call
this assignment again
and make sure to use this to refer to
this variable here
so this way we are getting updated
narrow height dynamically as well here
okay any side of our matte grid list we
want to add
another math component which is a child
of math grid list and that is matte grid
tile
okay and we will use this one to Loop
through the products array once we fetch
them
and now we want to create new components
so let me open up
the terminal
here
and change directory inside of the
source app
Pages home pages and components and
inside of this uh folder let's create NG
generate component and the name of the
component Let It Be
product box so this one will hold all
the informations for the products in
image a title description all these
things that we want to display about
about the products so as you can see it
created a new product box component and
and it updated
app.module.ts file okay
let me close that down
and we can go into components folder and
open up the products
product box
folder
here
what I want to do same as with the other
components let me just remove this
boilerplate and we want to create new
components uh HTML file so product
Dash box that component
dot HTML okay
and let's include this external HTML
file so template URL is name of the
property and make sure to refer to the
current directory like so
okay
and we can close that
now we can include this component so
make sure to use the selector
and include the selector inside of the
home component in the math grid tile
okay here
you can close the home component
and we can open up the product
HTML file and let's close the other so
that they are not confusing us okay
so here again we're gonna have
let me just
enlarge the browser and you will have
MAT card as the
wrapper again obviously
let's add some class so we want to
add text Center
[Music]
to the math card because I want
everything to be centered the title of
the description and all this information
okay so let's add another div
and inside of this div let's add an
image
okay
this image is going to have a class
MB
-1 which means margin bottom one
and MX Auto which basically adds an auto
margin on the left and the right side
and Center is the image okay
for the source
okay
and for the source you can use
placeholder images there's a great
website for it and just type in the
source like so https colon forward slash
forward slash via DOT placeholder.com
forward slash and this is the actual
size of the image that you want to put
in I just put it like 150 but you can
put whatever size do you want you know
so and you basically get like a square
well and you get the values of the image
inside of it it's very useful if you
want just have the placeholders while
you're developing something
okay
and let's add
height to be
200 pixels okay and this is how to add a
custom height to your properties H
stands for height and this way inside of
the brackets you can add a custom value
this is predefined value and this is the
custom value custom value okay
let's save that and this changes uh the
image size okay
now next to the image let's add another
div and inside of this tip we're gonna
add information about the product itself
so let's add a class
and set the width to full so this
basically sets the width to 200 percent
okay
and inside of this
uh do let's add another div
in here let's add
category of this product so let's name
it
shoot
maybe okay
then let's add a paragraph below that
okay
now let's add a class
truncate
okay and
hover
white space Dash normal
okay what this does is basically if you
have a text that is longer than this box
it cuts off the text and adds Three Dots
and when you hover over that text it
shows you entire text Justin hover
it's very useful when you have long
titles you know so that's a title here
like sneakers Maybe
okay let me just change the view to
Beaver wrap like so
and that looks nice
and now let's
add another div here actually
description so let's add a paragraph
here and for the description Let's uh
just add dummy text description and we
will update that later on okay
uh actually I see the text is not
centered and that's why that the reason
for that is because we miss here that
the text
the T on the end okay that's more like
it
and now below this div
okay we want to add another div
and let's set a class
flex and justify
[Music]
so here at the bottom I want to display
the price and I want to display here uh
proceed to the checkout basically uh
I'll actually to add to the cart so cart
icon so that we can add this item to the
card
yeah
so get a span here
and let's add we use the class
text Red 400.
and let's use the currency pipe again to
display the value of the older price
let's use 150
and just use the pipe
currency
like so and it displays
the currency in correct format and on
the right side I want to add a button
and inside of this button let's add a
matte icon
but icon okay like so and let's add icon
as
shopping underscore card
okay
and let's just change the color of this
uh of this icon class and set it to text
Dash Gray
Dash 500.
okay that's much more subtle
okay I think this looks very nice so the
one thing that I want to change here is
basically depending on your body's the
layout select that we want to change
uh this layout on our product box a
little bit so when we are in full screen
mode basically when we only have one
column like in this case one column per
row we want to show the image on the
left side and we want to change the
description the title in all this
information on the right side here
so that it takes more more space
actually right and the image is bigger
so how we can do that is we can create
an input here which we will receive from
the parent component
and let's call that here
so import input
from angular core make sure to import it
on top here
initialize it and add a name full width
mode
and let's add a default value files
false because when we load our
application we will have three product
product boxes per row so it's not going
to be in the full width mode but only if
somebody clicks on this first icon it's
going to be one product box per row and
then we are in full width mode okay and
now we can use
uh this property to alter the sum of the
stars that we have okay and
actually before we do that let's go to
the home component
and we can set this property on the
product box so
it's in full with
mode only
if columns is equal to one
okay
okay
close that so if you go now and click
like so you can see that actually this
column is taking the entire place right
uh but it's not taking the full width so
let me go back to the home component
and set here the width
inside the class with full so it needs
to take the full width of this entire
container like so but the layout is
different so we want to change that okay
okay so here
the first thing that I want to do
is
I want to Center the text only if we are
not in the full uh full width mode so
here we can use mg class to create this
conditional right
and here I will add an object basically
an object and inside of the object add
text Center class only
if you are not in
full
bit mode like so and I will copy this
so because we are going to use this
quite some time
and also I want to change the height of
this image so where is our image it's
here so let's add again
NG class
and let's add basically
add a
add an object and let's add a height of
200. 200 pixels only
if we are not in the full height so
basically if we are in default mode
otherwise increase the height to
use the 365 360 pixels
that's really okay like so and make sure
to wrap that
in the quotes here as well because this
is the index of the object
and 360 if it's in full width mode
and I want to
yeah
put the
quotes like so
so let's try this
okay now switch to the full width mode
and you can see that the text is
centered
actually on the left side actually it's
not centered it's a line on the left
side and the image size it's bigger and
if you we switch back to the default
layout it's going back okay
the the different
layout we want to achieve
and still but we want to move the image
on the left side and this description on
the right side so how we can do that
is
we want to add
for this div we want to add property
Flex so let's add again NG class
and let's add Flex
if it's in full width mode
okay
like soy and you can see now it's in the
full width mode basically
on the left side
we have this and description on the
right side
but we still need some some more styling
because it doesn't look that great
either so we can go and add some padding
and the other properties so here let's
add
NG class
okay and let's add some pot padding left
in the on the right side
and let's add a flex and flex direction
to column and justify between
okay
okay like so
let me just
make sure to to apply this rule if you
are in full width mode and make sure to
surround
these classes
read the quotes
and that you're spelling is correctly so
what you're doing here here is we're
setting this div to the flex mode or
basically display flex and the flex
direction is two columns it's not it's
not for rows and we are just basically
justifying in between
if we save it
and test it
okay that looks much better he has some
space around it much much better
and I think basically we're done except
the fact that I want to display uh this
description only if we are in public
mode so go to NG if this is going to be
easy only it in in full width mode so
when we are on default we don't show the
description and when we switch on it on
the full width mode we show the
description yeah
okay
and that's all I wanted to do now let's
test the layout and how it looks if we
go to the home page and let's copy paste
it this metric tile a couple of times
I'm going to just copy it
like so
okay
let me just copy it I'll lose focus
for like five or six times like so
and let's see what we got
okay
so as you can see this is the default
layout where we have three items per row
and if you click on the first one on
this layout we get one item per row
and we can click on the third one we get
the four items per row and this looks uh
and it looks and works as expected with
this we basically have completed the
home page so we created everything uh
which which is static here but the only
thing that I want to do here now is I
want to implement the API
apart from this page you will have a
card page and actually we can first go
and create card page because maybe we
should start first with implementing all
the static files first and then we can
dig in into developing uh and
integrating the API into it so let's do
that first let's create another page
okay so let me close all these files
and let me open the terminal
let me see where we are at in the
directory and let's change directory to
the pages so City a couple of times and
now we're in the pages director here we
want to create new card components
or actually a new page component so run
the command NG generate component and
call it cart
okay
it will take a couple of seconds to
generate it like so
and once again we can close everything
and we have this card component so what
we want to do here is we want to set the
routes
you want to set new route in order to
load this page so let's just
copy paste this first route
and change the path to be car
the component that is going to load this
is going to be cart component
make sure that the car component is
imported at the very top here
okay and close that
we can close the terminal as well
and now let's open up the cart component
and let's test it out this route so if
we click on and now navigate to to the
card
you get this card Works which is actual
html text here right so once again
remove the Styles and let's give an
external HTML file
okay
so template URL
and make sure to navigate to the current
directory and we'll call it cart
dot component dot HTML
okay
and let's create that file
like so
okay well on this component we're gonna
create uh basically material table and
we're going to display all the
information before the user goes and
buys the product so we need to create at
the moment we don't have the real data
and we don't have the functionality
working for the cart itself so we need
to create a dummy card object and
let's do that
so we will have a card
which which is going to be the card
a card of type and we don't have this
type yet but it will receive the items
already
so let's create new folder
inside of the application and let's call
it models
make sure that is inside of the app
component not inside of the pages
and here we can create new file for the
card
so basically in this folder we will
create definition for our interfaces and
create new file and name it
card.model.ts okay
and the first thing that I want to
create is export interface just shrink
this down enter interface card item
okay and this card item is going to have
a couple of properties so product
is going to beat up string
name is going to be type shrinkle as
well price
is going to be type of number
quantity
is going to be type of number
and the ID of the card item is going to
be number as well
so here we are making the definition of
our data that we're going to receive and
pass through the application
and we're gonna export interface cart
this is the one that we just used in our
card component
and this one is going to have the items
array so it it's basically array of
card item that we just created here
okay
and with this we have created definition
uh for a card
okay so we can import that
here add import from Source app models
car dot model OKAY like so
you can save it and now let's actually
create uh some dummy object
you can just copy
you can copy the object definition from
here
so it's easier
for the product
let's just say
choose or actually uh the product is
going to take the image of the product
so let's just copy the placeholder that
we used before here
okay
the name
is going to be sneakers
price 150
I'm making this up so party one
okay make sure that you format the
subject correctly and for the idea let's
add the ID to one as well
okay like so so we have Now default
object
okay
and what I want to do next is we want to
add a property that we will use inside
of our our table so that property is
called data source
and this property is going to receive
the card item array you know
like so and make sure to Define it as a
rate
okay and
let's assign it to empty array at the
beginning right
and
we can assign in inside of the NG on and
it repeats the data source is equal to
this Dot card dot items okay
but once we hook up the API we'll fetch
the data and then we will feed this data
source from there okay the last thing
that I want to add here is I want to add
the columns so displayed
columns
call displayed columns okay and this is
going to be type string array
well
like so and let's just create this this
array okay so these are the columns that
we are going to show in the table so we
will show the product
name second one I mean I could copy
paste but yeah this will work as well
price
uh the next one is quantity okay
the currently
the next one is going to be total this
is the total amount that the user needs
to pay and the action uh column in this
column we're going to display a couple
of buttons so if if user wants to remove
the product from the table from the cart
actually okay
let's save this
and let's open up the cart so now we can
start creating our table
again you already know we're going to
use math card for a wrapper
and uh we will only display this ngf
the
card.items.land is existing so basically
only if we have uh you know the length
of the of the card items otherwise we
want to show a message to the user so
let's copy paste this
that user needs to buy something in
order to get uh display to this product
right so what we can create here
and you can add a paragraph that says
your
card is empty
and let's add a button where you can
navigate back to the home start shopping
and let's set it
matte
raised
button so basically we are assigning
raise button so uh quest to it
and router link so that they can
navigate to the Home where they can see
uh
the products so let's change the layout
to wordbrap so you can see everything
and if I save this for now as you can
see the card items length is empty and
basically it's not actually uh it's it
shows both of these uh cards because
we use where the card item length exists
we want to show this only if there is no
card item land
and about how we can test it is
basically we can just remove this
this first item that we have in inside
of the this array
and we should get yeah we should get
this and we get redirected here
how we can get back is we should click
on view card because we assigned the
card route here okay let's give back
this product to the items array and we
should see our card
which is empty because we haven't
created anything yet there so let's
start creating our table okay
so let me shrink this
and here on top let's create table
let's add a probably math
table like so
and data source here we will pass the
data source that we created
like so and let's add some classes
so let's add a class
Matt
elevation
elevation
a lab
C8 this is going to add you need to make
sure that you spell correctly otherwise
it's not going to be applied in the
application
now this is going to add some Shadow on
below the table Yeah and set the width
to full
also I want to add a container to our
matte card so I can add class actually
the maximum width of our container so
add a maximum width to 7 Excel this is
the same as we did on the home page and
let's Center it so use the MX Auto and
this is something which we can use for
the bottom red card as well here
so if we go and check out here
if you enlarge
actually you cannot see it because it's
big but here you can see when it's on
100 basically it's not taking the full
width of the window it has the maximum
width okay
like so
okay
and now it's on inside of the table
let's add the First Column or actually
we can first add the rows so we'll have
actually three type of rows first one is
the header the second one is the regular
row and then and the last one is the
footer so table row here and the first
one is going to be format header row
like I said this is for the
40 table headers
and it also needs to have that head row
definition so Matt another
row definition and this one is going to
be the display columns that we created
here
okay I have a typo called
like so columns
here and make sure to add the to Matt
had the row definition here
okay
let's create another one
so the next one is going to be for the
regular table row
so Matt row and again we we need to have
Matt
row definition
and here we're gonna Loop to the items
so what we're going to do is we Define
let row
and basically columns
are going to get information from these
paid accounts here
okay
and the last one is table footer
so again Matt
footer
row
and we also want to give it a definition
matte footer
row definition is equal to these plate
columns
[Music]
so these are the placeholders in which
we are going to render our uh table data
right
so table cells actually so this is what
you want to create first and now you can
go and create these columns so let's
create NG container
like so
and the first one is going to be product
so matte column
definitely it stands for definition it's
going to give you a product this is the
the key that you're accessing the data
source so it needs to match with these
columns basically from the items itself
so if you want to display a particular
property from the object you would use
this math column definition here
now you can access that
so let's add a table
header for this one and let's add a
definition to it so matte
together so this is important in order
to add all the functionalities that
Matt's table has so you when you add
this this property to it it can add
additional like sorting or filtering all
these things that material table has so
that's why you're writing it and you
want to test match together
cell definition
okay and for the title we're gonna
say this is going to be product
and now let's create a table at the
actual table cell and for the table cell
you need to pass the math
cell and again Matt cell definition
and we will go we will Define what is
the name of the element
and we'll just call it elements and this
is how we access the property from the
object with with this variable that we
Define in the math cell definition okay
so we can we can open the image
image attribute image of our element
sorry and the source is going to be
element dot product
so this is the product property here so
we will access this one this URL
element of product
okay
and make sure to surround that with the
curly braces so that you are inside of
the angular expression let's add an alt
as product
and let's add some classes class make it
width to be 100 pixels
okay let's close that bracket and let's
add some margin on the top and the
bottom to five pixels okay
[Music]
and let's create a footer
photocell so 3D
let's add again
matte footer
cell okay let's add a definition for
this footer mat footer
cell definition and you can only this
amp you don't have to assign anything to
it so in the footer we want to display
a button here
which will say continue shopping
basically
Matt
is going to be the same but we can just
copy paste it from this one
but we will update the text to continue
shopping instead of start shopping okay
continue shopping like so let's save
this and see what we got
okay uh we don't get anything displayed
in our table let me just check the
console okay I have some error so let's
debug it together
and the reason why we are getting this
error is because
as you can see here we Define these paid
columns and we are defining name so it
reports the name error because the
product has been found here if you have
the medical on the finishing product
right but we are missing the name so if
we go and remove these products here
these columns and just comment them out
we should get the first column right
for two to make the table work as we as
we expected but as you can see the first
column has uh the table header here
product it has the table cell with the
image here and at the bottom in the
footer it has a button that says
continue shopping like so so let's
uncomment these others and let's add
them
okay
now let's just copy paste this container
and for the second one the definition of
the column is name
the title of this one is going to be
name obviously instead of the image
we want to just display the elements
dot name
okay and what we can do here we can just
copy paste this one a couple of more
times
actually
uh yeah
for the bottom I don't want to display
the continue button again so let me
remove this button so for the
footer cell this is going to be an empty
right
and uh for the for this one as well I
want to apply some style because some
names of of uh particular products could
be very large very long actually so
let's apply
uh one class so that we can actually
truncate the width of the of the title
so let's add phone k and the maximum
width is excess
so we are setting here the maximum width
of this element and if it's longer than
this maximum width it will just cut it
off and show the dots that's what I
wanted to to display now I can copy this
and paste it so the next one that we
need uh is price okay
so the title
the column definition is price
the title is price as well
and here instead of the paragraph
I mean we can use the paragraph
but
let's just add the property price
and let's use the currents
but as well
or we can even remove the paragraph
because we don't we don't need to apply
any Styles whatsoever
okay
and let's copy it again
the next one is quantity
let me copy that so the math column
definition is quantity
the title is also quantity with upper
first case and the property is quantity
but we want to remove this currency pipe
here
okay
let me copy this one
and paste it
the next one is total
okay so the marathon definition is total
the title is total as well and here
as well for the toll we just want to
add element dot total
like so
and on the footer you actually want to
display because
we will have on each row the total
amount
how all the prices and on the very
bottom we want to display the the total
grand total amount so let's just add a
here let's just add
new span
here let's add some class font
Dash ball so make it bold add some
padding five
and let's
now let's set the display to block in
order to apply this padding and so we
need to set this block
and we'll create new method get total
and we'll pass the card
dot items and again we will use
the currency pipe make sure to wrap that
inside of the
angular bracket so it's in inside of the
expression
okay and let's define this get total
method inside of our card component so
here
so this method is going to return
[Music]
number
and it receives in items
which are type of card item
array
okay and what we want to do
is we want to go and map items
dot map
and here we can access the item and what
we want to do
you want to take the item price
and multiply that with item dot quantity
so here what we are doing basically is
we are going uh looping through the
items
and we're taking the item price and the
quantity that it has and then we want to
add all of that so we can use reduce
and instead of we reduce we always have
the previous value
and the current value
so and all we are doing here is
basically taking the previous value and
adding the current value on and we need
to set the initial value here which will
be the zero
okay
and it shows the error here because we
are not returning the number you so we
will need to add return in order to
satisfy satisfy this rule okay like so
and now we created this method let me
just indent it a little bit so
let's start in the same line okay
and so using this method we are getting
the total price
total price for Insider uh card
basically not not just per product and
row but for the entire you know entire
card yes okay let me see that was the
total and last one is the action
[Music]
okay
so let's actually copy paste
previous
column and let's copy paste the
definition so it's action
and for the title we don't want to say
we don't want to add the title actually
but we want to add a button here so
let's add a button
and we will use this button to clear
to clear
entire card clear all so to style it
let's add a matte
raised button so this transforms the
director button into matte matte button
and let's add a color worn so that it's
actually red
color
worn and let's add a class
float
right
okay so let's save that let's save this
one
foreign and we get our table as you can
see here
what I wanted to add
a part from the buttons on top I want to
add buttons Pro as well here so let me
just find that so here instead of the
element the total
okay I can remove that and here on the
bottom
I can remove the total as well
here
and here we want to add an icon
so basically inside of the button
and let's add a class off
Matt Mini
Fab
okay
this will give us like a small button
with the rounded style styling okay and
let's add a color
worn so it's red
and let's set a class
float
right like so
and the name of the icon is closed
okay so we get actually yes the name of
the icon but we need to import the matte
icon element and just name it as close
and we get this button nice and styled
okay and if we go and just let let me
try and copy paste
this product once again like so
and change the like the ID to two for
example
we will get two items per row and we can
remove you know each and one of them
okay one thing I'm noticing here
actually is that we are missing the
total values here so these need to be
total values per row so if you have
quantity like two or three or five and
this is the total value that you're
getting so
if we go go to them to the total
column actually can see that we are
using element total and that's something
that we don't have so what we want to do
here is element dot quantity
like here
times element
dot price
and let's format that in the currency
pipe as well
okay
and let's wrap it
to the
apprentices like so and now let's test
it
and as you can see we get the values and
what if we go and change the quantity
let's say for the second product we have
three items
this one
and we get 450 the personality is 150
quantity is three and now the total
price is getting updated
but ideally uh to increase the quantity
we want to do that here so let's
add a couple buttons so that user is
able to update the quantity if you want
so let's wrap the spam
with the quantity and let's add a couple
buttons here so let's set a button
for removal of the for reducing the
quantity and let's style it with matte
icon
button like so
now let's add matte icon inside of it
and the name will be removed okay
like so so that user can remove and
let's add another one
afterwards and let's call this one add
and actually this is the actual name of
the it's not that we are calling it like
that so is the actual name
of the button okay
and you can see that this sneakers is
not actually online with all of this
element and the reason for that is
that we are using the paragraph So and
it adds some margin on the bottom what
we can do is
we can change this
into span
here
and
and it gets aligned and make sure to
add actually we can we can test this so
let's see if it works or not so let's
add some gibberish long text and see if
it gets cut off
as you can see it doesn't work
the reason for that is
we need to set the property block to it
and now it works because the span by
default is not a block element so okay
it doesn't work
okay let's just remove this rubbish tag
and let's
add the element name and don't forget to
add the block display block property
okay the last thing that I forgot to add
here I think this looks nice the only
thing that is missing is we want the
actual button to go and
to you know do the actual shopping right
so to proceed to the checkout so let's
find the actions here actions column
and for the footer let's add the button
for that let's add a button
and this button will say proceed to the
checkout
okay it's gonna be
uh it's going to be math raised
button
and it's gonna say
Pro seed to
check out
you can make this one uh color set the
color to be primary so it stands out and
let's float it to right so let's add a
class quote right
okay
let's go back to card and here we have
the procedure checkout
okay instead of implementing the API
first I think that it makes much more
sense to First implement the logic of
the card and when I say the card I mean
uh let me just enlarge this and when and
when I say card I mean by adding and
removing the items from the card right
in reading them on different places for
example if you want to read the items
from the card
here on the menu and we want to read
them here as well on this card page so
let's Implement that okay
uh let me actually
minimize this entirely and we can focus
more on coding here so what I want to
open here is I want to open the home
page
and on the home page
with your product box
here
and I want to add a new event basically
so on this button which is basically
this shopping cart here I want to add
this product information to the new
service that we will create just in a
bit
okay
so let's add a click
on quick event
let's call uh
on add to cart
okay
now let's create this method so let me
close all the other files
let's open the typescript file here
and let's add this method
so this method is not going to be
returning anything so the return type is
void and we are also not passing
anything so what this method does it's
going to emit the product that we are
going to get from the input but for now
as we are not getting uh as we don't
have anything we are not catching the
actual data let's create this product
as uh as a diamond datum and the type of
this product is going to be
product but yes we don't have this
product uh
interface created yet let's do that so
inside of the models create new file and
name it product.model.ts
[Music]
like so
okay and now let's create new interface
export interface
product
and this interface is going to have an
ID with step number
title which is type string
price which is type of number
category
step of string
[Music]
description
which is type of string as well and the
image
this type of string so these are all the
properties of the product that we're
gonna use
and we're exporting this make sure so
that you are able to import it in the
file that you need so here we can just
go and import it on top so import
product make sure that it's imported
and now let's uh it can be actually
product or undefined because once when
we implement the API we will pass this
uh through the input same thing as we
are doing here here with the full width
mode and while it's fetching the data
this product can be undefined for a
little bit of time right
but now let's uh create an array which
is a dummy data and we can just copy
from this product the object definition
so it's easier to create this object
number let's add one
title
what we can create
we can create sneakers
sneakers
price 150 by the way I'm not sure if the
spelling of synchronous is correct so
sorry about that if it's not category
shoes
[Music]
description
I'll just put the description board
and for the image again we can use the
one that we are using here
placeholder
okay
so instead of this string let's put this
placeholder and like so
okay now what we can do is we can go
and
use this product to emit
but in order to tell me this product we
need to create event emitter so let's
add an output
again this is the way how you
communicate uh with the child and the
priority component
okay output and we will give an event
name to add add to
cart which is a new event
emitter
okay and make sure that you import both
of the output and event emitter on top
here from angular core
and what we can do
we can call this dot add to cart and
emit
our product this dot product
so it basically means that somebody
clicked
uh on this shopping cart and he wants to
add this this product to the shopping
cart yes
so now we need to catch this this method
in inside of our home component so
let's go to the let's close
these components
and inside of the home component let's
scroll to the product box
actually we can remove these ones and we
will
create Dynamic ones later on so from the
app product box
okay we have new event
and let me set the view to word wrap as
well here so that you can see
all the classes okay
and the attributes okay so we will get
an event which is called add to cart
and we want to create new method here on
add to cart and for all the events that
I'm passing from the child I'm using the
same attribute name which is called the
event that's just naming convention that
I like to follow
but you don't have to obviously
now let's create this method now it will
try an error because we don't have this
method created yet so on add to cart
and
uh this method is going to return
nothing so the written type is void
and we want to create a new basically
service that we are going to be using
where we can store the date the actual
data so let's do that inside of the app
folder let's create new folder and call
it services
okay and actually let me just
comment that this is how to cut because
it's showing us an error and it looks
like we are doing something wrong I
don't like to see errors okay let me
open up the terminal
and
let me see where we are at so we are at
the pages so City on the upper the right
directory and change into Services okay
and here we want to let me just clear
the console and here we want to generate
NG G for Generate service so s is for
service and the name of the service is
going to be cart service okay
let's take just couple of seconds to
create this service okay so it created
this card service but you can see it
hasn't updated the app module so we will
need manually to import this service
so if you go to deep Services you have
the card service and what we want to do
is we want to go to app.module
and we want to inject our service
in the providers array here and make
sure to import
from the card service here so so that we
can use it and it's imported here on the
top
okay I can close the terminal
and save this up close the module
and now we can import this service or
actually we can first Define all the
things that we want and that we need
inside of this service
so service is going to hold one property
that will be used across our application
so it will be named cart obviously and
it's going to be new Behavior subject
here and you need to import it from rxjs
okay and the type of this Behavior
subject subject is going to be card
so the card model that we defined in the
in the models card dot model okay
and we need to set the default value
which is going to be uh object with
empty array of items like so
so why how do we use this card uh
Behavior subject is basically it holds
the initial value and once we update for
example we add new products to the card
it just adds new value to these items
array and in every single component that
we want inside of our application we can
subscribe to this behavioral subject and
we can receive the new values and update
the UI that's how it works okay so in
this card service we want to add a
snack bar
stack bar components so we will use
private underscore snack bar and the
type of this uh Services called math
math snack bar like so so make sure to
import it as well here on the top and
what this component or service actually
does it displays the information to the
user so once we add the product uh to
the cart we want to display the
information that we have successfully
added this product right so now let's
add a method add to cart
this is the method that we I was talking
about so this method is not going to be
returning anything so the type is going
to be void because we're just going to
update this card
uh object and we're going to emit uh but
we're gonna have a item receive and the
type of the item is going to be card
item
okay
and make sure again to import it on the
top
so now we're gonna create new items
array and this is going to be
because we don't want to affect uh this
default
this original card object so we can
destructure that object and create new
array and we can just go reference to
this Dot card
dot value we're accessing this Behavior
subject with the value
dot items okay like so
here and now we can
find the actual item because uh when
we're adding items inside of this card
we could be adding the same product
multiple times so we just want to
increase the quantity and if there is no
such product inside of the card we just
want to add it right so let's do that
so let's define const items
in car so we are trying to find if there
is there is this item already added in
the cart items
dot find and
[Music]
here we have an item
and we're just gonna check if the item
the ID is equal to the item that we
passed here it's argument
dot ID
so if this find method finds an items an
item it means that this is not going to
be null
or undefined so we can check here if
if it exits if it already exists in the
card
in the card we just want to increase the
quantity so let's just item
or actually this is not multiple this
should be a singular
item in card so if item in
card
is there
just increase the quantity by one
let's use the shorthand plus equals one
otherwise we want to push
this to the items array so otherwise we
want to else we want to use items
dot push
this item
okay
so otherwise you're pushing this new
item to this items array
in all and what we want to do at the at
the at this very end this Dot card we
just want to emit this value so that
every single component that is
subscribed to the card can catch that
value so please Dot card dot next
and we can emit the object with items
so basically this is the exactly the
same as writing items or items but the
shorthand is just to remove the key and
value and you get the same now what we
want to do is we want to open up the
snack bar these third underscore stack
bar this is that service that displays
the user's information so it's very
useful
and we can for the first argument we
want to pass the text one item added
two card
and the second argument you want to pass
the text that you want to show on the
button so let's say okay
and the third argument is object and we
can set the duration of the of this uh
pop-up of the stack bar so after this
amount of milliseconds it's gonna close
so let's set it to 3000 which means
three seconds it's gonna it's gonna
stand there for three seconds okay
and now let's just uh console.log
uh this Dot card dot value okay so that
we can see in the log what we're
updating
and here inside of the home component we
can inject the service that we just
created
okay so go to
private
card service
and imported card service
okay so it's important on the top from
Source app services card.service
and now we can use this service okay so
here I'm going to add to cart we are
actually receiving the value here
from this event from App product box
okay
and
this parameter is product
in the type of this is product
product interface that we created as
well here it's imported on the top in
the models product model
now what we want to do is we want just
to call this dot servicecardservice dot
on add to cart and we want to pass an
object okay so the product is different
from the cards card item so we want to
uh send different parameters
or actual properties so the product is
product
product
dot image
the name
is product dot title and this is the
beauty of the typescript you'll get all
the properties uh you know show it to
you so you don't have to think about
them the price is product
dot price
quantity
quantity is going to be 1 because we are
just setting one item and the ID is
going to be product ID
dot ID okay and if you're wondering why
the naming Convention of this uh
interfaces is like this is I'm I'm
mapping uh the API that I'm going to be
using and that we are going to be using
in this tutorial uses these exact name
fields so this is how I created this
object so that they match the API data
contracts so that's why that's the
reason for it okay so now let's go and
save this home component let's say the
HTML file and let's try to add an item
to the array so if I go and inspect we
should see uh the value of the card
okay let me clear the console and
enlarge so you can see it
if I click on
one item has been added to the card and
we can close okay or actually close this
out to three seconds and we get log from
the card service if I expand the items
we can we can see that inside of the
items array we get now one product and
we get the all the information that we
passed now let's test if we click again
we should get still one item but it
should increase the quantity
to two Okay let's try that
so let's click again one item added to
the card okay and let's see we again get
uh the same log from the card service
and if we expand it
we can see that the quantity has been
increased to two so this works as
expected
okay the next thing which I wanted to do
here is I want the actual card menu to
be updated because as you can see we
added two products but still it says
here one and we want to make this
Dynamic and to Loop through all of these
items and to show the actual price here
so let's do that
so where we can handle it all of this
using the cart components so let me
close all these files
and let's open up
the header components in the app folder
and let's open up the headers
here and what we are going to have in
this component is we're going to have
cart which is going to be subscribed in
the home component and passed in this
header component so
will help private
underscore card this type of card and
let's initialize the default values so
it's going to have the items property
which is going to be an empty array at
the beginning
and make sure to import a card
the another thing that that we we need
is the items quantity
as you can see right now we are
displaying this static one value but we
want to update that
based on the number of items and the
quantity of those items in the in the
in the card itself
engineering is not going to be used in
our in this component so we can actually
remove it
if you want to use a little bit of
cleanup and here we want to receive the
actual card so we will have an input
let's initialize it
so make sure to import the input
and we will create a getter and Setter
that's why I'm using the underscore the
card because this is the naming
convention that usually programmers do
when you have underscore card it means
that this is the private field okay so
we will get set here together so get our
card which is type of card
and we'll just return this
uh underscore card here so this is the
getter and now let's set the setter so
to set card
fill the receiver cartridge type of card
and here we will set this
card equals to the card
and also every time that card changes we
want to update this item quantity
if we don't have a field for iOS
quantity so we need to actually create
this logic so what we can do is we can
you can use this item quantity and we
can Loop 3D card items
colored items and what we can do is
first we get the object with different
fields but we only need the quantity
here so so what we need to do we need to
add that we need to map our item
and only get the array with with the
quantities so item dot quantity
so what we are doing here is basically
using discard items array and instead of
the objects we are transforming that you
only have the quantity and then we can
use that quantity to add up and get the
final items quantity so we can use
reduce
to do so and again reduce uses the
previous and the current values as
argument
and you need to set the initial value
which is zero in this case and all we do
is we use and add the previous value
with the current value
and we get the final quantity so again
views the items array which is basically
a array of color item objects let me
transform that into array of only
quantities and then we just add them up
right and that's how we update the items
quantity okay
and now what we can do is we can go to
our HTML file and we can update
let me see
where is our
okay so here we have actually one items
and we can update this value to be the
quantity items
just copy the property name and it's
quantity
like so and for the Mad badge here
we can also add this value so it's
Dynamic okay so at the beginning is
going to be
always zero and we want to check
if it's zero we don't want to display it
so set the map
that you can use this property for that
math batch hidden
equals if
if there is no out of quantity so it
should it should hide it
okay let me just see
okay I have a typo here
I have uppercase i
so let's say again and as you can see it
removed this icon
okay what we can do here is we can check
if uh do we if we have items in the card
then we want to display this this part
if we don't uh we don't wanna so let's
add NG if
basically uh we want to say NG if
if there is uh sorry card dot items dot
went like so only if there is car items
dot Lan we want to show this uh this
this div and now let's Loop through
record items and display this
information
so what we can do here
you can just use ng4 Loop
or equals let
item of card. items
in here instead of the keyboard
you can use
item Dot
name
and here we can use that in the quantity
item Dot
dot quantity
like so
and here instead of the this hard-coded
price we want to use the price
or actually just item dot price like so
okay
and for the total here
we want to use the get total
method that total method which we
actually created already in the Pro in
the card component
so
price
card actually
item.car.items here
card dot items what we need to pass is
we want to pass all the items to the get
total method so that it can go Loop
through all of them and calculate the
the final value right
and let's use this method let's create
this method so inside of the header
the total this one it will receive
return actual number
and it will get the
items
items away
of items which is actually added this
type of array of
card item okay
net card component card item okay like
so
and what we want to do here is showing
the error because we are not returning
anything what we can do is we don't want
to duplicate the code that we have so we
can go into Pages card and card
component and get this method which is
already created get total here
you can copy it
inside of our service and access this
method from two places
so here we can
add this method
and now inside of the card component
you can call this
method so let's add private underscore
or actually card service and name it
card
and add the type of the card service
make sure that the card service is
imported on top here and now we can
instead of
and Define this method we can just call
this uh start service method so return
this Dot card service
and return the method that we just
created get total and plastic items
here
like so
and we can create this exactly the same
method
in the
okay let's save this
exactly the same method here in the
header and it will receive in return
uh the the total amount
okay so what it's reporting is that we
haven't imported the card service so
let's do that private cart service right
private means that we are going to only
going to use this inside of our class
component we're not going to use it
inside of the HTML so if you want to use
your services inside of the HTML you
would avoid this private keyword
okay card service and let's add the
definition of the cart service and it
and make sure again it's imported on the
very top here
let's save this and let's save this and
the last thing that that I want to add
here and since we are on the shopping
cart let's add a method for removing or
actually clearing the shopping cart okay
so what I want to do is I want to add
a new method
here on your move shopping cart
so when you're on click event
let's add uh on clear card this method
is not going to receive any argument
because
you just want to empty the card animate
on clear card
okay so and we want to let me say this
and I want to create a service inside of
the card
so that actually it can be used on
multiple places okay let's go to the
card service
I can remove this log that we had before
and here let's create this method here
this method is not going to return
anything it's not receiving any
arguments
so the only thing that we are doing here
is here is we are emitting the empty
resetted value for our cartilage so we
will just call the next with items array
empty
okay like so and we can display this
information to the user this style snack
bar dot open
card is clear
and again let's add okay text for a
button and let's set the duration
duration to 3000 milliseconds or three
seconds if it's easier for you now let's
just call this method inside of our add
a component here
please Dot card service
dot clear card okay
like so
and now we have completed everything
except the fact that we are passing this
card object so we need to subscribe to
our card service for this uh actually
for this Behavior subject and we want to
update our menu
as you can see right now this is empty
but if we add something to our cart we
know that it gets added because we
logged it and tested before but if we
open up our card it's not getting any
values so it's because we are not
sending this card object
uh to this to this component so where we
need to do that is close this header
component and open up the component
where this scatter component is placed
and that's inside of the our root
component
so that's inside of the let's just
in the app component here
okay we have here app header
you can remove this title we are not
using it and we can create new cart
property in the name and the type of
this card property is going to be card
and let's add the default values like we
use yeah but like we usually do so the
items array
like so and it's empty array now we want
to implement the NG on init
life cycle hook
on on in it and make sure that it's
imported from the angular core
now let's implement it so here energy on
connect
[Music]
this basically method runs when the when
the components are starts initialization
okay and we want to include our card
service in the Constructor so
let's define the private cart
service
this type of card service
here and again it's being imported on
the top
and now when the component is
initializing we want to call this Dot
card service
and we want to subscribe to our cart
property
so subscribe there
and it will receive back a card once it
gets updated
and all we want to do is we want to
update our card property here this card
is equal to cart
okay
and now what we can do here is we can
use this card and pass that to our
header component
and that's exactly here
so cart is equal to
uh card let me just created
okay
and let's test this out so now we should
get this card component updated as well
so if I click
you get here notification that actually
we get one item added there and if we
open up we can see that we have one
items and it's basically sneakers
quantity one and this the price and this
is the total price let's try to increase
the quantity
so we have added another item we get the
quantity to two and we actually see that
we added a quantity two so let's see if
we add additional product
so let's say or actually I think this is
enough for just testing purposes later
we will try with the actual data but for
now it's it's it's okay so the next
thing that I want to apply is once
somebody uh
ask a product to the card he wants to go
to view the card and here we want to
update this card page be the cart as
well so we need to subscribe to the card
from the card uh page component as well
and to Loop and display all this
information there as well so let's do
that so in order to do that let's close
the app component and let's open the
Pages folder and open up the cart
component okay
so here we want to subscribe to our new
created cart item
so let's just call this Dot card service
Dot
cart dot subscribe
here we get back
new card
which is type of card okay
and all we want to do here is we want to
update our card with this new one
underscore card okay like so and let's
set the data source
here two card items
okay
[Music]
let's refresh
your card is empty you're not saving
this into local storage this could be a
fun exercise for you guys but for this
tutorial I'm not going to handle this in
the local storage so every time that we
actually refresh it's going to lose the
state you can fix this with local
storage and sell save all the
information there
so let's add a couple of uh items to the
card and now let's view the card and as
you can see we got two uh items in the
in the card and it's actually displaying
now this information so the next thing
which I wanted to implement is let's
implement this clear all so that we can
actually clear this card so let's add
this method
so on clear card
it's not returning anything because we
just want to clear a card and here we
will just call this Dot card service
dot clear card we already Define this
method
okay and now we want to
call this method
this method on clear card once you click
on the clear all so let's find this
clear all button so it's under the
actions
here
and let me grab this so
you can see
view word wrap so you can see everything
and here on the button let's add clear
all let's add a click
click is equal to one clear card
now let's try again so start shopping
let's add one item
let's view a card click clear all and
card is clear and we get the message
okay
start shopping so what we want to do
next is
let's add so if I add some products here
new card so let's add this clear so we
want to remove only this rope so maybe
we have a couple of items maybe we have
like three or four products in the card
and we want to remove the specific one
so we don't want to clear entire uh card
so let's add that method so
let me just see where that method is so
it's on this here on this element
okay
and let's add a click event
here
click event
and the name of this event is going to
be on remove
unremove
from card make sure it's camel kids
okay copy that
let's head over to the card component
and here let's create a new method
and it's going to be called
on your mobile phone card
okay and actually we need to pass an
element here
because we want to remove only one
element so only move from cart and let's
pass the supplement
okay
any side of the only move from cart is
not going to return anything so return
type is void but it's going to receive
an item
which is cart item okay
and we will gonna create this method
inside of this service so this Dot card
service
[Music]
and we'll name it remove from cart
you from cards like so
and we'll pass an item here
now let's define this method the card
service
open up the card service
here
and let's add this new
method it's not
it's not going to return anything it's
just going to update the cart object and
emit that
so what we are going to do here we're
going to receive item
this type of card item
let me show you the part item like so
and we want to Loop through the cards uh
elements so this is the card
dot value dot items and we want to
filter there are multiple ways in order
to remove an item from the array but we
can use filter for this one you can
choose your own way so basically we get
the item inside of the loop and you just
check if the item dot ID
is not equal to item dot ID so basically
all the elements all the items in the
array that are they don't have the ID
from this item are going to pass this so
we are only removing one item from the
array and we want to store this to new
constant and name it filter filter
items like so
okay and all you want to do now next is
we want to update this Dot card dot next
update the items
complete filtered items
and we want to show corresponding
message to the user did these dot
underscore snackbar dot open
and the message will be one item
renewed from car
Dot and let's add control
text okay and let's add duration
to 300 milliseconds or three seconds
again
okay
okay let's save this all this stuff
and we can try this now so start
shopping
and let's add a couple of items into
into the card you can view card and we
remove actually this is not going to be
tested properly uh because we only have
one item in the card but once we are
added the API you can see that we are
only removing the row and it at the end
as you can see it works as expected one
item has been removed from the card
okay the next thing that I want to
implement let me just add one item again
and so
what I want to add is basically I want
to add this quantity feature so we want
to be able to update the quantity inside
of our cart page
so let's create it so let's first uh add
the addition so this is going to be
easier
so we want to find this method for the
quantity
here a quantity and this is the button
for removal and we want the button for
addition okay so let's add a new
event click
click and on click we want to add new
method which is called on ADD who wanted
to
be okay and it will pass the element as
argument
so it's this element okay
and let's add
this okay
sorry my mouse is jumping around let me
just see on ADD remove from card and
foreign
quantity here let me copy it
and let's add this method here
when you have the quantity so this
method is again is not returning
anything
but it's accepting the item
which is a type of cart item
and this method has already been created
so we will just call this the service
card service dot add to cart and we'll
just pass an item and it will go to this
card service and this add to cart method
and you'll check if this item is in the
card
if it is it will increase the quantity
and since it's already in the card it
should increase the quantity right away
so let's start start shopping
add item to the card okay now let's go
and view the card and let's try
and yes the quantity is getting updated
as you can see
and the total uh price is getting
updated as well the total and here the
total
okay the next thing that you want to add
is to remove the quantity which is not
working
but let's add that so let's go to the on
ad quantity and let's add new event
let's copy this
here let's add new click event here and
for this one
let's call it on remove quantity
one remote quantity okay
like so let's copy it
in here let's add this method and remove
quantity is going to be similar
uh like the previous one so it's going
to have items
what are actually the item that is
called Adam
his argument and it's not going to
return anything okay and we are going to
create new method because we don't have
this method in the cart yet so but let's
call it this Dot card service
dot on or actually just call it remove
one DT okay and pass the item
now let's copy this
method definition and let's create new
one
okay so let's
here in the card service let's add new
method here and this method is going to
receive new items so just add item this
card item
and the return type is going to be void
because we are not going to return
anything
okay
now let's
what we want to do here is we want to
Loop through the array of the item same
as we did here on the on the on the add
to items but we want to Mark what is the
quantity that we want to remove so
face Dot card Dot
value dot items and just map
we access the item inside of the array
here
and we want to check
okay if
this item
the ID is equal to the past item.ie is
it if it's equal to this one so this is
the item if you want to remove the
quantity so
here we want to remove item dot quantity
let's use the short syntax minus minus
so here we are removing the quantity but
the one thing there is one Edge case we
want to check if the quantity is zero so
it basically means that uh this this
item should be removed from the card
right so if if we hit like zero if if we
are like on five we just hit minus minus
and it's four and that's fine we're good
to go but if you are like on one and we
hit minus minus we hit the zero and it
means that this product needs to be
removed uh from the card so what we can
do is again check here if item
dot quantity
is equal equal to equal to zero we can
actually mark this item for removal so
let's create another uh variable let
item or removal
and this is going to be part type of
cards item or
undefined
okay
so if if this is the if the quantity is
zero item for removal is equal to item
okay
and then
once we updated this we can just return
the item
mapped item
return
[Music]
like so so here we are mapping the this
array and basically we are updating the
quantity property
and once we map uh this array we want to
store this inside of the variable so
let's call it flat
filtered items
like so
and now we want to check if
we Mark any items for removal and we
will call the method that we already
created for removing the items from the
card right so if there's item for
removal called
this Dot
uh remove from cart and pass in filtered
items
or actually yes I don't know actually we
need to pass the item for removal
so it's this one okay
because we only want to pass one one
argument
one property
and we want to update the filtered items
okay
with the results that we have
and filtered items is returning in an
error what is not accessible to cart
item
okay let's see so what is not assignable
to
filter items so what we can do here is
we can set the type
but actually
we are not returning anything from the
car so that's why it's uh showing us the
error so we need to return something
from the card here
okay another thing that I want to do
here is not only that I want to remove
from the card but I also don't want to
duplicate the notifications so as you
can see if we add the notifications here
this dot discover stack bar
dot open
one item removed
card
and let's click
let's add the OK and the duration
inside of the configuration object
duration to 300 milliseconds you can see
here and we also want to obviously this
Dot
a DOT card the teammate the new value
right these dot next and we want to emit
the items filtered items okay
but the problem with this is you're
calling this remove card and it's also
notifying the user
so what we can do is you can send a flag
so
uh
like so at a flag do we want to notify
the users or not and add here one
property so notify
or even update
update
which is equal by defaulty true
and here we can check
if
[Music]
if we want to update
then
I'll update the card and send the
notification otherwise you will get two
notifications and we also need to re uh
to return something so that we actually
get this value right
okay so we just need to return from the
remove from card these filtered items
okay
so return
filtered items so it means that we are
returning
array
off
cards item
like so and now it should work
if we save it
let's try now
so start shopping
let's add a couple of items in the card
actually seven of them now if we go
let's try minus we're reducing the
quantity
in plus we are increasing the quantity
and let's see what happens if we hit the
zero
boom it empties the shopping cart and
with this we have covered most of the
use cases that we wanted for our
shopping cart and the last piece of our
application is left to be done is
basically we want to implement the API
so let's do that next
so let me close all these files and we
need to create another service and this
service is going to handle the API
request to this fixed or apis so in case
you missed it you're going to be using
pick store API and the links to this API
is going to be in the description
obviously and I highly advise you to go
into reader docs there are much much
more properties and more endpoints that
we are going to be using in this
tutorial but just in case you want to
check and maybe you want to build your
own version of the uh store you can go
and check it out it's uh the good thing
about this uh fixer API it's really easy
to access all the data that we need and
the Simplicity is what you want
especially when you're just learning all
these
topics okay
now let's open up the terminal and we
are in the in the services folder and
what we can do is we can go and type in
NG generate service and name it as store
this is going to be uh actual
store service yes so click enter and it
will take a couple of seconds
to make it and once again we want to go
and import this service inside of the
providers array into the app module so
here store type in store service and
make sure it's imported on the top here
now let's close it
open up the storage service the service
that we just created here okay
so
here what we want to do is we want to
import the HTTP client first so this is
the client that we're going to use in
order to fetch the data so add the
private HTTP client and the type is HTTP
client here and it's getting imported on
the top from the angular common http
and let's add the base URL for our API
request so add a constant
store underscore pass base underscore
URL and the URL is HTTP s which is the
secure protocol or four slash forward
slash
fake store
api.com okay
like so and we want to create a get all
products
method
and this method is going to receive two
arguments the first one is the limit
and set the default limit to 12. and the
second argument is going to be sort
which is going to be the default sorting
which is going to be this which stands
for uh descending right
the return type of this uh this method
is going to be observable
and make sure to import it from the rxjs
and this observable is going to return
the type of product array so array
product
and again uh make sure to import this
product from on the very top it's
showing there because we are not
returning anything at the moment so but
we're gonna fix that just in a second so
return
this dot HTTP client
and we're going to use get method here
and this get method is going to return
array of product
here
oops not that just array of product here
let's copy that
okay let me just type it in
array of product okay like so and then
inside of the parentheses let's add the
first argument is the URL of of the API
so let's use the page URL
store base URL and then you just use the
four slash products
okay with this you will get all the uh
the products but we want to apply the
limit and we want to apply the sort as
well so what we can do here we can add
now question mark sort is equal to and
let's
add the sword
and we can also add
a limit so limit
is equal to
limit
okay
and with this we can get our products
and the place where we are going to call
this is actually in the home page
component so open up
we just shrimp down this middle and open
up the home page component and here
inside of the NG on in it we're going to
call this com uh call this method but
first let's create a
the variable where we're going to store
this so we're going to store this inside
of the products
a variable and it's going to be the
property type array of products
okay
and at the beginning is going to be
undefined so that's why you need to pass
the undefined type as well here
uh we need to sort
variable as well in the default value is
just descending and the count
is basically the number of items that we
want to display right so let's set it to
12 which is default one okay
okay and we want to have an
production products
uh subscription
products subscription uh
variable this variable is going to
contain our subscription and once we
destroy the component we want to remove
anything because we don't have we don't
want to have any memory leaks I will
show you how to do that so the type of
this is going to be subscription
you can import it from rxjs here
like so and at the beginning
it's going to be undefined
okay
now we want to import our service inside
of the Constructor so here let's add a
comma private
store service
and type is store service okay and again
make sure to to import that from our
services folder here on top
and now inside of the engine in it we
can call this
foreign
so that we can call a couple of times
when you're changing the filters the and
the other uh other sorting and showing
the columns menu uh functions so let's
create this get products
method and this method is not returning
anything or receiving so it's just going
to update the products here
so uh this dot let's call it this dot
store
service
dot get all products
and what we want to pass in is we want
to pass this dot uh count
and twist.sort
okay like so
and then we want to subscribe to this
method
and once we receive the products
products
we want to update our products
property
these dot products equals to underscore
products
like so
and don't forget the products
subscription
so what we want to do is we want to
store this subscription to this variable
we use this.subscription
product subscription and equal to this
and now what we want to do is we want to
implement NG and destroy
on Destroy and make sure to import the
on Destroy here on top it's reporting
the error because we are not
implementing NG on Destroy and we are
set at VR so what you want to do here is
mg on Destroy and it's not returning
anything so we got this nice Auto
completion and we just want to check if
this Dot uh products subscription exists
so if we created a subscription we want
to unsubscribe is the product
subscription Dot unsubscribe otherwise
if you navigate to home page and card
page for a couple of times
you may end up creating a couple of
subscriptions and uh you will result in
memory leaks and that's something that
you don't want to have on your
application especially as your
application grows you may start losing
uh keep start losing the track of it so
what we want to do now is we want to use
the app products box here basically and
we want to Loop to the array
of the products that we just attached
here actually we may end up with an
error because I don't see my layout so
let me see what we actually got here
oh actually it's reporting that we
haven't injected HTTP client inside of
our HTTP uh inside of our app module so
what we what we need to do uh basically
we are using inside of our store service
we're using this hdb client but it's not
imported inside of our
application so what we need to do is we
need to go to the import survey
an imported http
HTTP client module here and now we can
use the HTTP requests
close that
and are up now our application is back
you can go to the home component that
because the store component and let's
use
these products
array and now let's go to the HTML file
and let's
make this Dynamic product box so on the
matte grid tile let's implement the ng4
and G4 and let's product rate product
variable of products and what we want to
do is we want to pass this product to
our air product
component so here
product
is equal to product
[Music]
now let's go to the app product box
which is in the components folder
product box here
and we want to add an input for this
product so here we are hardcoding this
but we want to remove it
and we want to create this as an input
okay now you can save this and save this
and we should get our products here so
let's see if this works
okay I see uh this works because we are
getting some more products that we
created but actually the only thing
which is missing is on our product box
we're using the static data that's a
problem
so what we need to do is instead of
creating this uh static data we can
actually use the product that we just
got so let's do that
here in the source
we can use okay
you can use product
dot image
for the H5 we can use this is the
category so call it product Dot
category
okay let's save that up
okay so product image it's not possible
because our object is undefined so what
we want to do here is we want to check
if we do get the product or not
otherwise
or we can even check uh we can check on
two places so one one of the places
where you can track you can check here
so basically you can do NG if product so
this way there's not going to be a
chance that this product is undefined as
as you can see here we're getting the
images and we're getting the categories
the sneakers is uh snack bar so it's a
chocolate snack bar it's not the shoes
so this is wrong naming everything is
wrong so let's fix that up
how we can do this is we can access the
property of product
dot name this is the name of the product
let's change the view to the word wrap
so you can see everything for the
description
we can add
okay let me just see product name so
property name doesn't exist on type
product okay this is a good thing of the
typescript or let's see what is the name
of the actual product uh the name is the
title actually okay so product dot title
then for the description
as you can see now it works and you can
see now that we have that front truncate
uh class it's working so we have this
very large title and so it's cutting
this off and once we hover over it shows
the entire title
okay
so what is left to be done so once we
switch over on on one uh one product per
row layout we get this description which
is static right now so let's fix this
okay
let me just
increase the
this layout okay like so
and so for the description we want to
use the
product dot description
here and close the brackets and for the
price we want to use the product dot
price
here
product dot price
like so
and let's test now
how it works okay as you can see we are
getting these prices different now
so we're getting these titles we're
getting this uh these categories and if
we and if we change the layout mode we
get a description as well here
obviously the format of the images is
not exactly the same in every product so
this is why we get these inconsistencies
but I don't mind that to be honest okay
so this is the the different layout
Inlet now let's test if we add different
products to our card item so you can see
we add a couple of items we added four
of them and you can see we get the the
description we get a title we get the
the total amount that we are uh with we
are supposed to pay so if you go and
click on view card you can actually see
that you get all this product updated
into the card and here we can update the
quantity
like like I said uh and we can remove
the quantity here and we can remove the
one item per row and we can also clear
the card let's test that out here
and we can now return back
so uh the thing which I wanted to
implement next is actually let me just
show you
so the thing that we want to implement
is once we click on the sort description
or sort by descending or ascending or
when we click on show 12 or 24 or 36 we
want to fetch again all these products
and send different parameters
so what we need to do is we need to go
to
the home component here
and inside of the home component we want
to catch this sort and account being
changed so the actual component that
holds this counted sort is the actual
app products header so here in the app
products header you're changing these
values and we need to emit these values
so let's open this file
in here
basically we have this sword and I'm so
count we want to create this as output
so let's create two outputs and emit
these values so we can just
copy paste this a couple of times
and let's rename these two items count
change
and the last one is going to be sort
of change and it's going to emit this
string type
okay
so when you change when we change the
sort we want to emit the new value so
this Dot uh sort change dot emit
and we want to emit the new value which
is basically new sort
okay
and on the uh items count change
or
yes
we want to emit new value so this dot
items count change
emit new values so account
like so
and don't forget to emit this field
okay and now we can catch this item
count count change and sort change
inside of our home component so let's go
to the home component and here let's
change the view to word wrap
okay and let's add two more events
okay
and let's copy paste the name of the
event so the one the first one is items
count change okay
so this is the basically when you're
changing this item count so 12 24 36
so basically we need to set the limit to
the request
uh items count change and then we want
to call the method
on
items
account
change
event and let's create this method here
inside of the home component
and let's add it here at the bottom
and item is called change this method is
not going to return anything so it's
going to be void
but what is going to be it's going to
receive
a new description so description is
going to be a type of string or actually
not description sorry this is going to
receive the count which is going to be a
number
and we want to update this Dot
count is equal to count
or we can rename this to new account so
let's be done you have the overlap for
the new account like so and we want to
okay so it says that it's not assignable
to string so what we can do is see here
is we can
change this to string okay
so we can change this format from number
to a string
and then we can call again this Dot
get products so what we are doing here
is basically we are updating the con
count variable and we are calling this
get products
a method which actually uses this dot
count and this.sort on the second method
we want to update the sort and again
call this product so let's take this
sort change
okay
home
so this is new event Source change
and we will create new method on sort
change which will also send the Sorting
new sorting value
copy this save it and let's create this
new one so
on sort change
and we will have new sort
this type of string
it doesn't return anything so the return
type is void and we will update this Dot
uh the name of the property is 200
update you sort this dot sort
is equal to new sort okay and then again
we want to call this dot get all
products because we want to
I'll catch again
and with this let's test it out and
let's open the console so that we can
see if uh we what is the the actual
values from the network tab okay
let's refresh the page
okay and we get the first
initial request which actually sends the
sort is description a limit to 12. what
if we set the limit to let's say 24
refresh is the page
it says the new request which is fix our
API products sort is again description
and the limit now is 24. what if we
change the value to the ascending
it refreshes the page again and sends
another request and now the sort is
ascending the limit is 24. so as you can
see this is dynamic and these filters
work as expected
uh the next thing we should we want to
do is we want to use these categories so
as you can see this is starting now so
we want to fetch all the categories uh
that we have
and we want to once we click on this
category we want to display only the
items and the products from that
category so let's do that we need to
open up
the
services and let's open up the store
service
okay so we need to get so we need to add
another method
here so the name of this method is
yet all categories
in this method
doesn't return doesn't accept any
parameters but it returns an observable
observable
and the type of this observable is array
of strings array of strings okay
like so so we want to return
please dot HTTP client dot get
and uh
this get method it will return again
array of strings
okay
like so and then inside of the
get method we want to pass
the base URL which is
store
base URL and then we want to add forward
slash
products
four slash categories
like so
okay
now we can close this store service and
we want to go into inside of the
uh home component and we have filters
inside of these filters we want to
include this store service here
and as you can see
as you can see we are hardcoding the
categories here so we want to
make this dynamic so include the private
service store service
store service and make sure again to
import it on the top and here inside
inside of the engine in it this dot
store service dot get all categories
call this method
okay
and then we want to just update these
category so these categories
actually needs to be
undefined at the beginning so
it's array of
strings and or undefined
like so and what we want to do here
we are basically getting
you need to subscribe
here without subscribe
and when we get view response back
once back we just want to update the pro
the categories array these dot
categories equals to respond
okay
and also don't forget that we want to
create category subscription variables
so that we can unsubscribe once we leave
the home page so let's name it
categories
categories subscription
and this is type of subscription
imported from rxjs and we want to assign
this variable here
categories subscription
again
let's Implement NG on Destroy
on Destroy here
and let's add it on the very bottom on
this way
and we just want to check if this
subscription exists if
this Dot
category subscription
exist
if it's if it's not undefined and
actually it's showing the error because
it doesn't have initializer and that's
why because at the beginning it's
undefined so if it exists we want just
to unsubscribe from it please dot
category subscription Dot
unsubscribe like so
[Music]
okay and basically
this component should be working now as
you can see we get all these values but
now we need to catch this uh event
emitter that we are emitting these
categories inside of our home component
and update let me just close
this value and
this files actually let me just see what
is the type of the event
so inside of the filters the event is
show category so we want to when we
click on the category here
button click on the category we are
basically emitting this value here
and we want to Cache that inside of the
home component so inside of the home
component we have this show category
actually we have already this this
method created so this show category and
we are updating this category so now
what we want to do is we want to call
this get products
here this
Target products like so but the only
thing that we that we are missing inside
of this get products
is we are missing this category
so this dot let me change the word wraps
so this dot category so that we can
actually apply this category to the
actual request so
now we need to need to change our get
our products
method here and we need to add
additional
property so let's add property which is
called category and make it as optional
that's why we add this question mark and
the type of this is just string okay
and now let's add here so so here
actually after the products we want to
add another
expression so we want to check if there
is a category string
there's category string we want to add
four stash got it
category and just add this category
otherwise we want to pass an empty
string like so
so basically what we're doing here just
change the word wrap so what we're doing
here is just we are just checking if
there is category if it is we're adding
the category namespace and the category
itself otherwise we just return the
string so it the API endpoint Remains
the Same so let's test that out so if
you click on the categories and let's
say we click on the men's clothing
and as you can see we only get these
products for the main closing if you
click on jewelry you get only the
jewelry if you click on the electronics
you only get the electronics and it's it
works as a spec that and the last piece
of the puzzle is to integrate the
payment and the checkout and the actual
ordering flow so like I said at the
beginning of this video is that you need
to go on shop.com and you just need to
go and to create your account so just go
to stripe.com
and you need to sign up here
so I already signed up and once you are
signed up and signed in you can go to
the dashboard
and once you access the dashboard
there's a section for the developers so
here on the right top you can click on
the developers and
in the test mode you need to activate
your account in order to get the real
live data so here we have the API keys
that we are going to be using inside of
our application in order to integrate
the stripe okay so let's start doing the
implementation
let me close all of this
files and the first thing that we want
to do is we want to install a stripe.js
package that we are going to be using so
make sure that you're inside of the root
folder and then let's do npm install
let me just shrink down this window npm
install add stripe
or slash stripe Dash JS and the version
is going to be 1.35.0
like so
it'll take a couple of seconds to
install
okay
so once again make sure that you're
installing the correct version and the
same version as I'm doing here
and now we need to include the stripe as
well inside of the index.html file so
make sure to go to the basically source
folder and Target the index.html file
and we want to include this inside of
the head so add
a script
like so and just add a source
https
four slash forward slash js.stripe
.com and version three
and this way we have included the stripe
into our application
okay
I can close the index is index.html file
let me open up the terminal now and let
me just restart
or server
now we need to go to the checkout page
so open up the pages card actually card
page not the checkout page
and here we have checkout button
on the very bottom here proceed to the
checkout so we want to create a method
that will
call this checkout so here on click
call on checkout
method so let's call this method
here inside of the car component and
let's add it on the very bottom what we
can do
is we will add this method on the card
service itself so this method doesn't
return anything so the type is going to
be void
and we need to include the hdb client
here
what we can do we can also extract this
call to the to the service separatus a
different service but we can include it
into this one as well so
let's call it
private
HD3 now we are just including the HTTP
client HTTP client here and make sure
again that it's imported you just
enlarge it make sure that it's imported
on top here
and now inside of our on checkout what
we're going to do is we want to call the
stripe service and let me show you so we
are first making the post request so
this dot http
http
Dot HTTP client so we are targeting this
service
and make the post request
and the post request that we are going
to make is going to be the request to
our local server server that is going to
handle this post request and make
request by itself on the stripe then it
will return the session ID and using
that session ID we can open up the
checkout page so you will see
uh the URL of this request is going to
be HTTP it's going to be our local
server so localhost and we're gonna open
that up on the port
42
442 like so
and
slash
checkout okay
and inside of the object we want to
uh to pass items
so
this
Dot cards dot items and we can handle
these items inside of the server and
send that to the stripe okay and once we
get the response back so once we uh
receive something from the server we can
subscribe to it and this is going to be
async compression
and the result uh
we will put a type of any
because we don't have any type
definition here defined it's a little
bit outside of the scope of this
tutorial so first we need to load the
stripes so let's stripe is equal await
and this is why this is a async
compression because we need to load the
stripe here inside of this uh subscribe
subscribe uh scope so we need to use the
load stripe method from the package that
we installed so make sure to import here
import load Stripe from add stripe sap
Dash JS so this is the method that we
are using to load the stripe and inside
of the parenthesis we need to pass the
key that we have on our dashboard so
once again go to describe.com enter the
dashboard
and go to your dashboard once you're
logged in
go to the developers Tab and API keys
and the key that we need is this
publishable okay and click to copy set
copy it obviously you'll need to copy
your own key
it needs to be different than mine
obviously and let me close this and once
we load the stripe what we can do is we
can use a swipe
and we can call the method redirect to
check out and how we do that is
from the session itself on the server we
will return uh session ID and we just
need to pass the session ID and that's
how we open the checkout so session ID
is going to be result here that we
respond back and we will just return an
ID there
like so
okay
and now let me save this checkout now in
order this to work obviously we need to
create a local server and run it on the
port 4242 and create this post endpoint
checkout
so let's do that okay let me create a
new folder inside of the inside of the
root so just create new folder and name
it server okay
and let me initialize we need a new
node.js application so let me just
see where we are at we are in the root
folder
okay so CD into
server here inside of the server folder
we want to initialize new node
applications so run npm in it and
Dash why so we don't want any sub
questions we just want to initialize the
plane node.js application and here you
need to install three things so we want
to use express.js
a framework for our node application we
want to install the course because we
are going to create some across origin
resource requests and we want to install
the stripe obviously so let's run npm
install course
a version is going to be
2.8.5
the next one is Express and the version
is going to be 4.18
0.1 and the last one is stripe and the
version is
10
.7.0
okay and let me close this card
components and let me open up our new
server folder okay let's open let's open
up the package.json file and and as you
can see we have created this new project
and installed our three dependencies
here so now what we need to do is we
need to create our our main file so
let's name it server.js like so okay
and now inside of this
This Server let's create our application
so first we need to include the
libraries that we need the the good
thing about this server is and strike is
that they already built couple of pages
like success Pages redirect cancel all
these Pages for us so we will later on
just download these assets and place
them in the public folder and once you
complete the ordering we can redirect
users to these pages so we don't have to
build that part I mean you could but
this is easier and more faster okay
first import the express so comes
Express
this require
Express
the next one which we want to import is
course
otherwise if you don't import and use
the course it you will get an error when
you're trying to make the cross origin
requests so this one requires course
and the next one is body parser so this
one is for for parsing body uh the the
data that we're sending between the
servers so as it as it tells by its name
body parser
and it requires body dash parcel okay
like so so now what you can do we need
to initialize our application const app
is equal Express and we just call the
Express without any arguments there
the next thing
okay the next thing that I want to do is
I want to set the app to use the the
public folder so let's create a new
folder
public
and let me open up
the stripe
check out flow so let me show you this
so like I said they already have
checkout flow built yeah so let's
explore this
as you can see they have already built
all of this and so you don't have to do
this these kind of things and spend your
time into building like success page and
um maybe fail failures page so you can
go and click here on the top Explorer
documents and it can go on quick start
here
and once you're here you basically can
just copy paste all this entire code if
you want to but I can just go and
download this and we can use the
checkout success and cancel HTML files
and just include them inside of our
public folder
okay
just make sure it's downloaded
okay so here we have downloaded here and
now I can use this public folder and
extract it okay
actually I need to open up revealing the
file explorer it would be good it can
work directly from the zip file but it
doesn't so let's remove the public
folder and let's just include this
public folder here okay so in this
public folder we have this cancel HTML
checkout HTML and success HTML files you
will actually only use the cancel and
success the checkout HTML file is not
going to be used in this tutorial so
let's close this checkout
page and now inside of the our express
application app.use we want to use this
folder so in order in order to access
this
uh these assets from the public folder
we need to call Express dot static and
pass the name of the folder which is
public
okay like so
now we need to set the body parser so
call the app.use
and call the body parser and set the URL
and code it to
extended as false
this basically extended is by default uh
true so it enables the objects and
arrays to be encoded inside of the URL
which we don't want
so let me just copy paste this one and
also what we're going to do is we want
to create Json
Json application we want to use the
application slash Json for for app
obviously
and now let's use the course
so we need to set it up so app that use
and call the course
we need to set the origin so basically
we are enabling course here origin true
and we want to enable the headers as
well otherwise they will be omitted so
set the credentials too true as well
okay like so
and now let's see let's load the stripes
so cons stripe
this vehicle is equal to require
and now he here we need to include the
code
and the token from the stripe itself so
here we need to call the strike method
we're requiring stripe and then we are
calling the method with the key so once
again let's go to describe.com
here and let's go to the dashboard
foreign
let's go to the developers in API keys
and we need to open up this secret key
so reveal task key and we can click to
copy
we can close this now
and we can pass this key here to our
server
okay like so obviously like I said you
need to create your own servers and you
need to create your own keys right
here please don't use mine
okay
and now let's create a new post endpoint
so add the post
okay and the name of this request like
we created inside of the checkout so if
we go to the public folder and sorry
here inside of the source
app pages cards and here we created this
checkout endpoint so let's use that here
let's check out
and this is going to be async
callback so here we have re request we
have response and we have the next which
will handle the errors in case anything
comes up so let's build try catch block
here
you get this Auto completed from the
IntelliJ
sorry from the visual studio code and we
will create a session
variable which we will use to pass that
back to our request here in the cart and
we will pass back the ID from the
session so that we can open up
check out okay so
what what we are going to do here is
basically we are calling the stripe so
we are called await on stripe dot
checkout
uh check
out Dot sessions okay
and you call the create method
create like so you need to if you need
to pass an object
in inside of this object we'll pass uh
the data about our product that we want
to to you know to buy
so the first argument is line
underscore items
and here we will use the request that we
got in the body so request.body and we
will send as you can see here
from our client
here from our client we are sending
items
so we can access the items here request
body dot items
and what we want to do is we want to map
this array
okay
so
here we can access the item and what we
will return here
is a new object and inside of this
object let me just make an implicit
return
okay
so you just surround this by the
parentheses
and this is implicit return and now
inside of the object
set the currency
currency to be uh USD
like so
set the product
underscore Theta
to be okay new object and inside of this
object we want to pass the name and the
images so the name is going to be item
dot name
and the images we actually have only one
image so images but it accept the array
of images so use the item dot product
okay
like so
and this is for product data
then we need to send the unit amount so
this is the quantity unit underscore
amount
actually unit amount is the actual price
so you go to item dot dot price and we
we need to multiply that with 100
because they use that in sense and we we
want to use that in dollars okay
and
okay let me close this
the next uh parameter that we need to
send is the mode so the mode needs to be
payment there are multiple ways uh there
are multiple modes actually and there
are subscriptions one-time payments and
this is actually one-time payment so
that is what we are selling here and the
next thing is the success URL
success underscore URL so once the
payment has been done successfully we
will redirect the user to this URL and
actually let me make this double code
Codes as well so that we have
a same standard and the USD here
so let's use the double quotes here
always
okay so success URL is going to be the
the success HTML file from our public
folder
so-called httpe uh colon forward slash
forward slash localhost
four two four two and then success
dot HTML okay and then we want to
add Castle URL as well
cancel underscore URL and just add the
cancel file
what you can do now is you can obviously
go and update the success HTML file for
example here it says mail to orders it's
example we can do
collab or
code dot dot slower
you know add Gmail
.com
like so and copy paste this as well so
that we have custom
success page
you can make this much better obviously
but this is just this this will do it
right and instead of the catch error
we just want to pass the error back so
call the next
and we actually need to to catch the
arrow here and just pass the error back
like so and the last thing I forgot to
do is basically we want to return back
like I said the session so use the
response dot status
200 and respond in the Json format and
just having the session okay
so we are sending this session entirely
here and and the last part actually
which I forgot is to open up the port
and open up the actual application so
app.listen
and the port that we said that we're
going to be using 424242
and what you want to do is we just want
to cancel out
log
f is running
on
for two
four two four two forty just forty forty
okay
and now we can open up the terminal and
start our application inside of the
server run node and name of the file is
server.js
app is running on four two four two
forty okay and our client app is running
as well so let's try it
let me pressure the application
let's select a couple of products here
open up the card
let's go to the cart page
here let's continue proceed to the
checkout
okay this can this can take a couple of
seconds let me open that inspect tool in
case we have some errors okay we are
getting some error so let me just see
and if we open up
the console log we can see that the
request hasn't been correct so let me
see the server
what it says
okay let's see we are getting some
errors so item is not
fine we are getting
okay received unknown parameters unit
amount okay so obviously we have been
sending the wrong format so what we can
do is we can open up the stripe
documentation
here
and we can just copy paste the correct
format so inside of here inside of the
Align items let's just copy paste this
object
okay so here line items it's basically
this object
let's replace it here
okay
and now
okay let me just see we're mapping
here
we're closing we need another
brackets so make sure that you have
right spelling okay and now for the
currency
USD for the name we will use
item dot name
for the images
like we said we have only one image so
use the item dot product inside of the
array
okay for the unit amount we will use
item dot price and we will increase it
by 100 and for the quantity we want
item dot quantity
like so
let me restart the server
okay mode server
the app is running on 4242
okay let me
move this here
and now let me refresh to see what we
get so if I go now at the bottom you can
proceed to the checkout if I click on
that here
okay it's loading
and now we get uh our checkout page so
as you can see we have these products we
have the total amount and we have all
this information to fill in so we can
type in just test email
at gmail.com
for the testing you need to use 424242
[Music]
then for the month it doesn't matter for
CSV doesn't matter the name of the card
it's lava
and let's click pay
no thanks I don't want to save
okay we appreciate your business
and they basically got the checkout page
okay this is expired link because my
accidentally uh click on back
but if we go to stripe dashboard we
should check out and see if we got this
payment processed so let's go to the
dashboard
let's go to the payments here
and this is the last one
and as you can see we got our products
in the dashboard
uh and these are the details so slova
test Gmail and all of this so what we
can do and ask next is let me open up
our application again
local school localhost 4000.
okay let me just change the protocol to
remove the secure one
okay
so what we can do here is
we can integrate the shipping so it is
we have integrated the payments but if
you're ordering something you want to
integrate the shipping as well so this
is like just a donation uh but if you
want to add shipping options so you can
go to the documentation of the stripe
you have here stripe docs payments
checkout and the shipping and what we
can do we can just pass these shipping
options right
so let me see uh we have added these
line items and let me just copy this
entire part because
you can customize it but you don't have
to so let's copy it entirely
and let's see
okay
here before the line items let's copy
this shipping details
like so
and if you want to customize something
you can easily do that so but basically
the options are regular so here you can
update like the shipping countries here
is at U.S and Canada
shipping options
as you can see we have like the fixed
amount this is like free shipping so the
amount is zero the second option is to
have uh shipping for 1500 USD dollars
and you can like display name all these
properties you can alter if you want so
let me just in that this code okay
like so so let's try this now let's save
this
let's restart our server
okay app is running
and now let's test it what we can do
here let's select jewelry let's add a
couple of products
like so
let's go to the card your card let me
open up the console
so we can go proceeded at checkout
here
and let's see
okay we do get now the shipping as well
so as you can see on the other on the
left side we do have all the products
that we created and the total View and
the shipping is free
okay we have you know two options free
shipping and next day sir so if you
click on the next day sir you get 15 if
you click on free shipping it will take
five or seven uh business days so for
the email you can test we test at test
Dot
com name slova
uh address one test
I just do test
for the city
New York zip code
Virginia this is all random obviously
and for the card information 424242 just
for two
okay you can enter whatever you want
here for the CV
and if we want to go to pay let's see I
don't want to thank uh to save it's
recessing should be successful we
appreciate your business if you have any
questions please email call me swallow I
want to save this and if I go now to the
to the stripe.com
here let's open up the dashboard again
and let's see under the payments
here we have the last transaction and
here you can see
all the information so his key are the
owner information the address where you
want to ship your order and everything
looks as expected so with this we have
actually completed our application so
let me so let me navigate back and let
me review what we have created in this
tutorial so basically what we did is we
created this home page
with all of these products which we can
uh sort or by ascending or descending we
also created this menu where we can
choose different number of items that
you want to display on our current page
we also have the options to change the
layout depending on how we want to look
and we also have the options and the
filters on the left side to filter our
categories like Tony's Jewelry men's
clothing and so on also there are
options obviously because this is a
store to add these items to the cart you
can open the cart and preview what we
have there we can clear the card so this
is now empty
then again if you want to proceed and
buy some new things we can add them then
we can proceed to the checkout just
click on the Green
and here on the checkout we have list of
all the items that we added to the card
we can increase the quantity we can
remove the quantity if you want and just
let's say buy only this one man casual
sling fit uh
this t-shirt and we can proceed to the
checkout
if you click on proceed to the checkout
if you click on proceed to the checkout
we get this checkout form where we can
enter all the shipping details and the
card information and we can submit that
to our stripe dashboard and with this we
basically build our e-commerce store I
hope you enjoyed it and I hope you
learned something new well that's all
for this angular video thanks for
stopping by and don't forget to
subscribe
code with sloba
[Music]
thank you for watching the entire video
to see more angular tutorials click here
[Music]
foreign